John's dead.
I can't read.
I can read.
But I can't.
So you move.
Hello everybody.
Hi, hi.
Welcome.
Welcome to...
MOLLE, MOLLE, MOLLE, MOL.
MOL, MOL, MOL.
mom hi hi hi hi everybody hello hello hello how's the new
cafe so far so great besides my ac but my ac should be fixed
tuesday uh so for now i'm chilling with a big old fan on me
are you in the closet right now no actually i won't be able
to set up in the closet i think until my other stuff cubs i
gotta do some noise treatment on it so i'm a big fan one of
your fans actually though i got okay so gosh dang it i got
it i was like okay well i want a fan that's quiet but
effective so i'm gonna go for one of those fancy schmancy
wait what hold on obs is telling me something encoding
overloaded how is the stream okay
it's fine it's probably fine that oh it went away might have
been a little blip might have been a little blip moly moly
boo I have to fight the heck um but yeah I got one of those
fancy schmancy Dyson fans before you say anything it was a
good sale so i was like okay i'll grab the good sale i got a
previous some of you may not know this but what the very
first thing i ever i ever uh had a a uh what's the word
donothon was it a donothon i don't think so a money
collection I the first thing I raised money for in my
V-tubing career was a fan because I wanted something very
quiet for when I was streaming in the closet before and I
got this really nifty Dyson desk fan that I love oh my gosh
too bad it's so it's packed up in my stuff that won't be
arriving until July so I'm I was like okay well you know
I'll try out another one it's on a really good sale like I
was as it was a very good sale and so I was like I'll try it
out especially because my AC is broken and it won't be fixed
for a couple days and I get it and it is like every time I I
turn it on it shakes it like stutters it's like then the
gradually as you continuously use it it starts to go
so it is already going to be returned but i don't have to
return it until the end of july so uh we'll be we'll be
using it until my actual fan comes it's haunted i sure hope
not.
Annoying, that's what it is.
If it's haunted, it's an annoying ghost and you need to
leave.
Hi, Hemmington.
I hope you're doing wonderfully.
Thank you, Brandon.
Can the fan be miced up?
You want to hear it?
You want to hear it go, yeah,
I mean, yeah, it's one of those quote-unquote bladeless
fans, which I actually did not, I did not understand how
they worked.
I was like, what do you mean it's bladeless?
I for reason i thought like you know how they have like the
big tube like the round circle i always thought it was
something going really fast in there but then when i put
this together i was like oh the blades are at the bottom and
then it like pushes the air up something something the room
is hot because of me those in it oh yeah i'm smoking it
Touch my arm?
Stealth Blaze.
It actually is.
I adore my cheap little woo-zoo fan from Costco.
I went to Costco!
And I saw a fan that I actually am going to get instead of
this one.
I love Costco.
I went and got so many snacks today.
And I went.
I was like, I'm hungry for lunch.
And you know what?
It's the best.
the greatest thing you can do at a class go when you're
hungry is just go to all the samples bowl of ice water in
front of the spooky fan yeah yeah but the fan is actually
working right now I'm feeling nice my computer is not on
fire we're doing good we're doing good team we're doing good
the rest
um no hot dog i actually got a pizza i got a pizza and i was
like dang this thing is i haven't i haven't had a costco
pizza in so long that thing is massive it's greasy i ate it
and i felt the american dream inside of me i was like whoa
this is like the nostalgic flavor of a the greasy grease
pizza gives you 30 cents worth of samples sells you a fan
promotion working well i haven't bought the fan yay i'm
gonna look up some reviews and stuff
freeze the rest of the pizza it was so greasy i couldn't
even take it back to my cafe i feel less i feel like half i
i i feel half grease half ectoplasm at the moment but yeah
and then i i had my meeting today my weekly meeting And I
was like, Steiner, can we make this quick?
Because I have places to be.
And he was like, where are you going?
I was like, Costco.
I got, he was like, whoa, you gotta go get your double chunk
chocolate cookie.
Which I've never had before either.
Are they that good?
This is me and Brozky and uh, favorite show.
Let's go!
Double chunk chocolate cookie.
They're good?
They're definitely cookies.
Do they at least heat them up?
Yeah, five big boobs.
I too have learned the sacred palace of Costco.
The line for the rotisserie chicken is crazy.
God, everybody gotta get that chicken, man.
Refresh chat.
Oh, man.
I don't want to have to keep refreshing it during the
stream, so I might...
I was told of a different chat thing to...
have it stop freezing so i might have to just switch you
guys uh in a later date to something else it's youtube it's
youtube it's not me it's not even you it's you tube it's not
me it's you tube yeah doki seemed like she had a different
way to fix oh really i'll ask her then we might be collabing
i think we're collabing this week i think we're doing a
sloppy sisters plus NimmyFries, maybe some other people
collab.
That Mecha Chameleon game, we went to play it.
So, I'm hoping I can do my POV.
I'm hoping that the game is not too intensive for, uh, for
it.
For me and stuff.
Sloppy's back together.
Yeah!
And then, and then And there's also a Densetsu collab this
week.
On the Densetsu channel, we're celebrating 100k views on
Bird On!
Thank you guys for 100k views!
Thank you!
I have been...
I have been frantically...
Well, not frantically.
The choreo for that song that we got commissioned is a
little rough.
They're not rough.
It's really cool, but it's pretty tough.
So I've been struggling learning that choreo at the moment.
So I've had it on like repeat.
But yeah.
When will Vicky clean her keyboard?
We can ask her on Wednesday.
We can say, hey, Vickster.
When's it happening?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, she hit 50K, so she has to eat durian, too.
I saw durian at Costco today, and I was like, oh, man.
Okay, yeah, sorry.
Chat's going away.
It's being too stinky.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Durian.
I think it's time to abandon stream chat.
I will, I'll try to get a fix for next time.
Sorry, guys.
I keep forgetting.
I've been so busy with everything else.
I keep forgetting to...
Tomorrow!
Tomorrow I have a lot of stuff to do.
Ketchup.
Not mustard.
A lot of ketchup to do on things that are on my computer.
But I've been largely off my computer, off of my...
You know, not thinking...
I miss you guys, but I've been, like, thinking of lots of
other stuff.
And I gotta do some...
I gotta do, like, all the re-register.
my haunting like where I'm at I don't want another ghost
coming in here you know what I mean so it's just like when
you move addresses you have to register everything I gotta
do that too so so yeah take take your time to get settled
for sure thank you thank you I do I feel very strange you
know because like I'm on a temporary pc i my place is coming
together slowly but surely but i feel like i'm on like a
strange vacation i don't know like i have i have i don't
know i feel so out of my element um it's very weird
gotta settle in
technically the place is temporary too since you plan to go
to Japan well yes but also at the same time I'm like I
really do like it here I would like to stay I'm you know I
wasn't when my visa didn't get approved in time it wasn't me
like crying or anything I'm actually quite happy because I
you know enjoy where I'm at so you know if Japan happens it
happens and if it doesn't that's okay too Honestly, I'm
like, I'm just vibing.
And I do really like this place, so.
And I'm going to be streaming in my closet.
I'm not in my closet yet.
I got to soundproof my closet.
And also probably I'll wait until my desk arrives.
We miss you too.
I bet things will start to feel more like home once your
stuff arrives.
Don't forget to shred your old license.
Oh, thank you.
Well, I got to get a new license.
Lyme's brought me here so Happy for the future collab
already I love Lyme!
I love Lyme!
I'm so excited for the collab.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Yeah, JP is a huge commitment, right?
Phantom, stop super chatting and drive to dinner.
Is somebody getting called out?
why do lots of streamers move to japan oh i guess
everybody's reasonings are different but for me i well
actually i think japan is just extremely convenient lots of
people travel there so you if you have friends all over the
country or all over the world lots of people congregate in
japan in fact there's some people that i see more in japan
than i see anywhere else.
also, let's see.
It's very convenient because trains are easy.
You don't need a car necessarily.
If you want to go someplace, you can walk.
It's so like walking friendly.
And for me, I'm traveling there often, not just for idols.
But I go see idols a lot.
But also because I travel for work where it's like I gotta
go do motion capture and things like that so I wonder if the
taxes are better I have no idea honestly I think it's worse
because if you are living if you are from the United States
you have to do double taxes and that honestly stressed me
out a little bit thinking about that I was like yuck I know
right it's kind of terrible I definitely thought a lot, like
that's a part of the reason too that I was like, you know
what, I'm not going to cry about moving to Japan because
some living, it depends on, you know, if you're getting paid
in Japanese yen, it can be very expensive.
If you're paid in US dollar at the moment though, it's
pretty easy to live there.
Yeah.
Thank you guys for the super chance.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Minto, ohio, ohio!
Minto's model is very adorable and very beautiful.
Do not throw the Minto.
Actually, well, unless it's like...
She'd be Minto.
Wait.
No, no, I mean the plushie!
Not me, not me, not me!
Please do get the new license first.
I still get jury dates for places I used to live.
That's crazy.
The Nepolitan?
Oh, yeah, I don't like Neapolitan, though.
I don't like it.
I can multitask.
Why you call me out?
Phantom!
You hit 4-4-4-4-4.
Vicky and Phoebe did 50k.
And Vernon hit 100k views all in June.
Such an amazing month.
Congrats again, Vito.
Thank you, Phil!
That is a crazy...
It is Densatu month in June.
Let's go!
I know sold their house and moved into my place for a few
weeks until they got a new house they got to hang out in my
basement for seven months so glad I have a place I'm so glad
you have a place to be thank you Darko me too it's kind of
scary though I didn't get to see this place before I moved I
went off solely vibes I was like I was like the pictures
look pretty nice the landlord seems very nice it was full
vibes baby
Babycore, thank you so much for the fire, get in!
The Minto Fumo fit perfectly in the car seat.
It's so cute.
Hashtag Minto 2-Go.
Yeah!
She's kind of huge, though, no?
I think she needs a baby seat.
That's brave.
I know.
But I could, I did not have a chance to look, so...
Sentinel shipped my Minto plushie and others' merch!
She will soon join my Fumo.
Oh, it's...
Declan!
I haven't compared her to an actual Fumo, so can you do that
for me?
No, yeah, I didn't compare her.
I think she's bigger than an actual Fumo, though.
It was the babies.
Question, did you need a visa to move?
If I were moving to Japan, I would.
I hope my merch ships soon.
I hope so too.
I'll yell at Setsuna for you.
She is bigger than the Fumo.
Okay, I thought so.
I thought so.
Binto, I'm sorry I didn't finish my lizard drawing.
I'm still sketching.
You have all the time in the world.
I didn't get to...
Put them on the screen today.
I'll put them next time.
But...
Thank you!
The next time we will have the screen filled with lizards.
I saw immediately.
That...
I saw immediately that...
Um...
That...
People were posting them in my art hashtag.
It was so awesome.
There's some really cool lizards.
There are!
Wait, you're moving to Nippon?
I don't know yet.
What is the cost for an overseas U-Haul?
I was actually gonna go through...
The delivery service Kuro Neko.
Black Cat.
because I don't know they seemed like they were able to do
it and I was like oh well it's a Japanese company and they
have services I don't remember how much it was it was a
while ago that I checked this had been in the works for a
really long time basically I think what happened okay
backing up I talked to Shetsuna last year I think it was
like September, October that I was like, hey, I was told
that, you know, or rather, I want to try and do this.
Can you guys do this?
And they were like, yeah, we can try.
Was there another tag?
Oh, no, no, no, no, it's all good.
No, no, you're good, you're good.
But, um, I think because there was so many changes in
requirements and such that my visa even though the talks and
the discussions and the starting started in september
october of last year things didn't uh things didn't get by
the application didn't get submitted until april of this
year so i was like ah when i when i heard that because i
would be asking i'd be like hey did anything get happened
and about my visa and they were like well we're working on
it we're gonna work on it um i was like okay and then i and
then i got a random email from a lawyer lady in japanese and
she's like i'm working on your visa i just submitted it i
was like oh i don't think this is gonna happen a lot of
stuff out of your control yeah yeah yeah so it also wasn't
me being like hey let's do this like me being like last
month like let's do this tomorrow
but again i'm not even like upset the even the smallest
amount i'm just trying to uh catch you guys up with what's
been going on because it was i mean it was a lot of stress
for me because i was kind of twiddling my thumbs for a
really long time being like i know i need a move but am i
moving to japan do i need to prepare for that am i moving
elsewhere do i need to prepare for that so it was that was
the biggest stress about it was not just being kind of in a
state of limbo because if i were moving to japan i would
have to pack all my stuff differently than if i moved to
somewhere else so oh i don't want to talk about visa stuff
anymore i don't want to think about it i don't want to think
about it anymore i don't want to think about it yeah i can't
just move and move again exactly but oh sorry that was me
that was me flailing my arms i hit something um everything
is fine it is what it is we're all good everything is okay
i'm okay i'm okay she wriggled too much i'll be wiggling
i'll be wiggling i just sent a lizard a few minutes ago i'm
not much of an artiste so it took me a while Thank you,
Scooby-Gator!
Thank you.
Thank you for the Supertowet as well.
This game, everybody, we're mulling now.
We're...
It's a mole time.
I'm... Sorry, I just drank some water.
It went down.
The wrong pipe.
Um.
Mole.
I heard...
Or rather, I was watching somebody play this a streamer that
I watched that does a lot of like indie horror games and
things and I was watching it and then I was like this looks
too interesting I'm gonna stop watching so I can play it
myself I was like wait this looks really cool and the way
I've seen it described is mouthwashing cross iron lung and
when I watched my streamer play this this they were like
this game already has like crazy positive reviews so which
is unheard of so the game seems very neat i don't know much
about it except that we're digging a hole we're a little mo
they not an actual mo i think we're a person probably the
world needs more mitos cutie patooties i make everyone
around them days brighter the more mitos the better google
flags thank you
I might also leave for the same reason.
Understandable.
It's crazy, like 93% of positive, I think, for 1,000
reviews.
Yeah, I think when I watched him play it, it was like...
It was like 300 or so reviews, and they were all, like,
overwhelmingly positive.
And even he was saying, like, because he plays so many indie
horror games, he was like, play these games usually it's
like 50 reviews and it's like just a positive rating but
this one like came out and was like boom boom like hitting
every beat that people really liked so i'm very i'm very
excited about it the good thing about buying mint phantom
merch is that it's always an maimed card desert plus
two i hope that let's hope that it lives up to the hive yeah
yeah yeah yeah you think you know which streamer do you know
insim do you know that's my streamer that's my comfort
streamer insim and nimi nightmare which she's streaming i
was watching her karaoke before this oh nope oh people
always like to think that they know what i my streamer is
just some guy I mean, that was the oldest computer you've
ever used.
As old as the screen, when on screen right now?
I don't know that old.
I have vague memories of...
Someone's gateway.
It wasn't mine.
It was like my sister's friend had a gateway computer.
I remembered the cow logo.
And we would play cats on it.
We would play cats on it Because they owned cats
Yeah, yeah, the cow The cow And your merch is well made
But now I don't know about this old A computer that needs a
cassette But don'ts My granddad's Windows 95 PC.
Did you ever play cow clicker?
I'm always cow clicking.
Please understand.
Old gateways are the proper machines for mist.
What do you call mint phantom if she were a Roman warrior?
Spare mint!
Sorry, I'm workshopping some jokes I made in traffic.
Shall we play then?
Shall we play?
Disclaimer, I did have to put the...
There were only high settings and low settings.
The game doesn't seem so intensive, but I did put in low
settings.
And it seems like it'll be a several hour game.
Like, I think I saw like four-ish hours or something, so...
Let's play, baby.
Let's have a good time.
Six, seven hours.
Could be.
Who knows?
We have taken the calling in, calling it the white rabbit
signal.
What I'm about to show you is the best recording we have.
Just don't look directly at the screen.
We discovered it after the Matroska incident.
The frequency doesn't play nice with our instruments.
I can't stop looking at it.
All we know that it's calling from deep below the earth.
And that it most likely isn't natural.
Any contact with the signal seems to result in Cake?
Oh, whoa, I'm frozen.
Strange symptoms.
Whoa.
Am I back, no?
Most report hearing voices of parents, siblings, and old
friends.
People, they have lost.
I'm lost.
Even stranger, those voices all repeat the same word.
Dig.
The game looks good, though.
It's just me.
I'm frozen for some reason.
Encoding overload!
Wait, I am getting the encoding overload!
Uh-oh, is it lagging?
Wait, hold on.
Stream lagging.
Turn down video settings.
My video settings aren't even that high.
My video settings are very normal.
Oh man, why, why, why?
It won't let me change the,
oh my God, I'm seeing it on YouTube studio.
PC2 potato.
I
can't unfortunately change the aspect ratio while I'm
streaming.
I already capped the frame rate.
I already capped the frame rate, unfortunately.
Yeah, the audio is still good.
That's good.
I'm still getting that encoding error.
It looks fine on my end.
That's why I was like, oh, okay, things are all right, but
clearly not.
Let me let me see if we do graphics maybe v-sync on I don't
know if that'll do anything when I click back into the game
it goes crazy mode on me
but that doesn't now OBS doesn't want to properly output to
YouTube at the moment um
play past the field of hay and hope it works later.
But I want you guys to see it properly.
Lowering the FPS, oh that's right.
I did cap it, but we probably could lower it, you're right.
Okay, we're at 30 everybody.
Let's turn this off.
I freeze every time, it's OBS at the moment.
It's OBS at the moment.
And my back?
and my back and my back and my back and my back and my back
and my back we're back cool I changed the stream as well to
720 as well as the resolution of this to 720 and I freeze
every time I click back in the game I might have to
disappear you guys I think goodbye goodbye me this is so
painful It's more painful for me than it is for you, to be
honest.
Goodbye, me.
All right.
Let's get back into the game then.
Ah!
Where'd it go?
Wait, where'd the game go?
Wait, what just happened?
Uh?
Uh.
Oh.
Does anybody...
Wait, it's just a white screen for me.
Oh!
Okay.
Uh.
Okay!
All right.
Yeah, we're back to Bioshock, where I had to, where I was by
myself.
Oh, sprint, I'm sprinting already.
This looks like a nice little place to relax.
Like a 2012 Let's Play.
Heck yeah.
Petro Kaminsky.
1974 to 1980 just a baby oh no oh okay stream is quite
literally and technically haunted yeah that's okay we make
it work what do you want me to whoa my leg did you guys see
that whoa i'm dancing on this child's grave my bad i wasn't
trying to do it i wasn't trying to dance on the grave i was
just looking at my legs no can i oh i'm
still here oh oh it's like a golden freddy am i the baby
find me
oh starting to get shaky
Wait, did something just, like...
Did something just like pop up after the dig, like something
crossed out?
Or am I crazy?
I'm the real baby.
In honor of your brave PC, I have baked potato for dinner.
Ah, sounds awesome.
I want to bake potato.
Good morning!
Wake up!
I got the achievement.
Alright.
Whoa.
Alright, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, everything is mega, oh,
very, very nice.
Offer of enlistment issued March 9th, 1982, recipient, or is
that September 3rd, Victor Kaminsky.
So I'm a Kaminsky.
That was my child.
No.
So embarrassing.
You're of birth, 1939.
Residence?
Savodskia.
Yeah.
I have spoken to the committee again.
They are prepared to pay off your debts in full.
And they will pull some strings so that you can be
reinstated as a citizen again.
What happened to me?
Kaminky.
They are still skeptical.
But I believe they know as well as I do.
Oh, as well as I, that you were the best navigator still
alive.
This might be the last chance I'm able to give you to.
I know you will make me proud.
Signed, Director of Initiatives.
Stefan, oh, step, step, step, step, step, step, addamenco.
Strata Drilling and Exploration Division.
Neat.
Oh, look at my little mole!
So cute.
Anything else I can grab here?
Oh, what's this?
Inventory is tab.
I got some smokes.
Let's go.
What's that?
Oh, that's my alarm clock.
Grow.
I want to what?
I want to go deeper down than anyone.
Was that drawn by my kid?
That's so sad.
He wanted to be a little mole too.
What's that over there?
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
My mole son.
Data type key.
Dorm floor, deck floor.
Insert into a door panel.
Victor Kaminsky.
They know I'm divorced.
This is so embarrassing.
Step on me, please.
No.
Age 43.
Citizenship under a...
view criminal history yes what did i do responsibilities
navigator drill vessel piloting navigational course
corrections evaluating drilling intensity based on the
environment i wonder if this game is going to be pretty
spooky the music is a bob oh oops sorry i didn't think that
it would turn it off oops wait i'm actually stuck Oh, oh, I
wasn't stuck.
I wasn't pressing the right keys on my keyboard.
My bad.
Games are never spooky, so true.
The song is a bop immediately turns it off.
Do not leave in panel.
Oh.
Ooh, what was that?
Something was talking.
They know what you did last summer.
Couldn't be spookier than being stuck in the bathroom for an
hour while Doki watches TV.
The realist ever.
Can I put anything in here?
My cassette?
I hear like something going.
Row, row, row, row, row.
Place your bets on if there's cannibalism.
Don't, that does not count as me mentioning it.
is this talking to me
just gonna turn that right off because it's speaking in
tongues to me it's freaking me out a little bit I like the
cigarette right by the no smoking hold on watch this watch
this
oh wait I can smoke oh ha ha ha ha Cheers to your rules,
company!
How you like that?
I do a puff puff.
Yeah!
How do I get rid of this?
Oh.
That's definitely a fire hazard, maybe.
We got my uniform!
And everything.
You really are a criminal.
I know, I know, I know.
Welcome back to membership.
Thank you!
Last one.
What do you call Mint if she was driving around in a car?
Mint Mobile.
Criminal behavior.
That's my criminal background.
Engineer.
Oh, I probably will be able to go into his room eventually,
right?
I need...
Wait, can I stick my card in here?
here?
Let me in.
I need his card.
Alright.
Is there?
Okay.
The wreck room!
Let's go.
We got the bathroom here.
Is that?
Is that teeth?
Is that blood?
Is that a tooth?
That is Is that teeth?
I can't even see myself.
Oh.
And I'm such a monster.
I don't even put down the toilet seat.
We just gotta not go in there.
Maybe I don't need to go to the bathroom.
Communications room.
Oh.
No communicating allowed.
I'm just getting a little look around of everything.
Wow.
Beautiful sun.
said left the seat up i know that's what i'm saying that's
what i'm saying here was my room strata and stephan adamenko
so we have a bodon victor me right i'm victor victor
kaminsky this is a bodon this is the exit of course we can't
leave we're in our little drill let's see Bodan got
breakfast inspection lunch lunch lunch everybody's busy at
12 everybody's got things to do we're all together that's so
cute victor that's me I do course correction I can't read
that middle one at 11 sorry I think I I had to turn the
quality bed, so.
Rest, evaluation, report.
Hmm, something, something.
Well, the company can't be that bad if they're all giving us
a lunch break.
And it seems like they're enforcing it.
Everybody has to do it.
Geologist Yosep.
Okay.
Oh, anybody want to have a slumber party?
So here's my room.
How cozy and comfortable.
Lunch is dirt.
No, lunch is...
Ooh, lunches.
Oof.
Lunches.
A cold one with the bros.
A cold one.
If it's dirt, what does that even matter?
full of every nutrients you could iron magnesium quartz that
align you with whenever mercury is in Gatorade bugs protein
yeah worms have protein exactly exactly go ahead Minto
what's lunch do it no no all right let's see what's our
message today is november 9th night no november 9th 1982 or
also april 11th wait what was that date april 11th 1979
we're a little confused maybe mineral maxing let's see our
ship atmosphere we got a flow state flow rate stable
everything's fine our o2 is at 21%.
I have a feeling that's not good.
How do I read my messages?
Do I go to communications?
Oh, unread order available in terminal access communication
system and review immediately.
Uh, insert.
You?
Oh, this is all, this is all the stuff that I've already
talked about or done.
Oh, Oh, here we go.
We have to use the, uh, the I've Got Mail cassette tape to
read the mail, obviously.
I'm such a silly goose.
MOLMinto only likes everyone!
Is it coming?
Um, I thought I had a new thing, no?
Oh, maybe in here?
Oh, oh, I have to download it.
Okay.
inscribed okay okay okay okay all right we're figuring it
out everybody we're figuring it out message 127 m13 this is
Maria surface surface control what is going on I know the
white rabbit is disrupting most communications but You've
been at a standstill for over 12 hours now.
I hope this is just another Kaminsky.
Oh, am I the problem?
Another Kaminsky issue, but you must get him back into the
cockpit.
Oh, text is flashing, and I don't know if that's on purpose
or not.
Right now, you are far too off course for the autopilot to
keep up without a navigator.
Lock and Kaminto!
this is also a gentle reminder that all ship systems are
dependent on the power that is generated by the drill itself
oh including temperature control getting the drill moving
again must be your absolute top priority oh so if the drill
is working then that makes everything working oh geez why oh
okay yeah just a gentle reminder that you're gonna run out
of power and die if you don't move the drill otherwise
you'll be boiled alive in a few hours for now you will have
to divert power yourself by rerouting the fuse box on the
wreck floor i refuse to cancel this mission over one drunk
it's me oh no i'm sorry ma'am it won't happen again too much
is at stake We're all depending on you.
For tomorrow.
How's the audio, by the way?
Right now it's like a lot of ambiance, but...
Wait, I already read it, though.
Available in terminal.
So how deep are we, does it say?
Oh!
Temperature report.
Sounds good?
Okay, cool, cool.
is 26 degrees Celsius.
How cozy.
And the external temp is 132 degrees Celsius.
So, awesome.
We might be slowly being boiled alive.
Yeah.
Water turns to steam at 100.
Well, I guess it's a good thing thing doesn't sweat, maybe.
I don't know.
Oh.
Should these be flickering so much?
For tomorrow.
I see.
The wreck room.
Okay.
Oh, here we go.
So we have the water closet, our dorms, communication,
dorms, rec room, deck, engine hall, engine room.
So we're just going to be
I should all have a good feeling about this.
It's 80 degrees inside.
A little bit higher outside.
Don't be afraid.
Should I take this one?
I feel like I probably just have to leave it in here, I
imagine.
everything be flickering it kind of reminds me oh my gosh
there's this ride at Disney called well you know it's not
just a ride at Disney but you know 20,000 leagues under the
sea given those kind of like it's like a steampunk there's
like a what do you call the aesthetic where it's like
steampunk but water it's like Bioshock you know I think you
guys have told me this before
diesel punk Water punk, aqua punk.
You call it Bioshock.
It is kind of like a Bioshock.
A little less...
What was this one?
Oh, breaking through to the future, strata.
Okay.
Navigator.
That's me.
Oh.
Wait, what's that say?
Don't what?
Okay.
H2O punk.
I like the sound of aquapunk.
Aquapunk is pretty cool.
I'm sure it has a proper name.
You can't just call it Bioshock.
Right?
I don't know.
Anyway.
Oh, red means scary.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, give me out of here.
This is the fuse box.
Uh, this is the fuse?
REC.
fuse box fuse installation insert the fuse into the sockets
okay so we need more than one do not force insertion
misalignment may cause shorting okay load the calibration
rotate the middle selector knob to the match the amount of
fuses okay so one circuit activation press and hold the red
glowing charge button until the indicator light turns solid
green okay three six the number after that okay okay wait
what was it oh I'm scared uh this is one is this on one oh
that's on one one three six
wait what was that sound oh I forgot to press the button
oh What did I do wrong?
One, three.
I'm wreck room.
One.
It's on the correct thing, right?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I see it's on three.
There's an arrow.
It's hard to tell.
Whoa.
Successfully turned on the lights in wreck.
V.
Attention.
Vessel is off course.
course correction required.
Okay, uh...
Rupro.
Um...
Do I need to clean up?
Check diagnostics in the cockpit located on the deck.
Okay, so we gotta go down there.
Uh, let's, um...
Uh...
Shall we address the...
The...
The elephant in the room?
There's, like, text.
Oh, geologist.
This is...
Oh, ew.
Join the depth become a geonaut strata.
Can I watch TV?
This place is pretty set up.
I'm not gonna lie.
Except for the...
The dead man on the floor.
Okay, so place is definitely haunted.
You don't think this is gonna be like the thing kind of
situation, right?
Address me.
What
is this?
Famous geologist makes groundbreaking discovery.
No!
Was it him?
Signal found by Dr. Hirsenko.
Is something trying to contact us from below?
The frequency of the signal seems to change depending on the
observer, he says.
In plain terms, it speaks in different ways depending on
who's listening.
Ever since the Matroska incident, most citizens of the
sperm...
SPRN have in some way or another experienced something.
Earlier you talked about your comfort streamers.
I just wanted to say you're one of mine.
Eric, thank you.
Your voice, sweetness, and silliness help put me at ease
when I'm not doing well.
Thank you for that, Minto.
Thank you, Eric.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, okay.
We'll see what we gotta go.
To do heating system cycling irregularly.
not critical check about ballast ballast tanks again crew
fatigue abort three yeses one no stick oh gosh vessel is off
course okay
november 1982 wait when was that date was it november 11th
or something has it been a couple days since All of this
happened.
Oh, it's dark.
I thought I got another fuse.
I got another fuse.
Huge.
We could put this in the deck, probably.
It wasn't November 11th, it was a different month.
Oh, it was April 11th.
That's right.
Why we were playing cards.
What happened?
Did somebody go crazy?
nation puts faith in mole a strata m13 drilling vessel
affectionately dubbed the mole by its four-man crew is set
to depart later this week targeting the near impossible
depth of 87,000 meters mission director stepan adamenko is
hoping to locate the source of the enigmatic white rabbit
signal which experts believe may be causing the disturbances
currently plaguing the nation.
The M13 is by some seen as mining and energy conglomerate
Strata's attempt to set things right, after a previous
drilling vessel suddenly went missing at lower depths.
Its crew.
Dot, dot, dot.
Its crew is not doing so high.
Its crew is currently me?
Oh gosh.
Nice, Keeb.
Okay.
That's not great.
Cool.
Journey to the center of the earth.
Yes, it also has a very similar aesthetic to that as well.
And then some numbers.
Oh wait.
Stay awake.
Is this live?
Yes it is!
It is live!
I am currently playing.
Source of massive blackouts discovered.
Signal found by Dr. Hurtse.
So the guy...
Yes, yes, yes.
I know the vessel is off course.
I know, I know.
I can feel... I can see where the, uh, what's it called?
The iron lung part of this is gonna come into play if we are
directing the, uh, the ship back, you know?
Okay, so then, now I do this whole thing again, but with two
fuses, right?
Oh.
136 in the number after green I'm
so this is freaking me out you guys this is freaking me out
oh I think I need to put in mine my orange cassette oh it is
Quite atmospheric, huh?
I wish I had a flashlight or something.
Okay, it's not more blood, it's...
Oh gosh, my computer.
Are you okay, computer?
It's not so hot, it's just a little funky.
This goes to...
Something.
Oh.
It's a strata.
Strata everywhere, strata everywhere.
Fix vent.
We're venting?
I think...
Maybe I can't go into these unless I have the right key.
Did you think he had one?
Like in his pocket or something?
Oh, mogus.
I didn't see one, though.
Excuse me.
Do you have a key?
Oh, his ear.
Who van goad you?
I don't see anything.
Yeah, I don't see anything.
He looked like he pooped his pants.
That's so rude.
It's just a little brown.
I heard that happens when you die, but of course it wouldn't
happen to me.
Actually, I know nothing about that.
Okay, well, let's...
Yeah, we're gonna go fix the vessel.
Progress.
What?
Is this how many meters down we are?
We're at 6,000 out of 87?
Oh my god, sometimes I hear my own footsteps.
And it sounds like something is walking around, you know.
I know this is a spooky game.
I just don't know to what capacity.
You know what I mean?
Some office.
Nice back, Palo Minto.
Very smooth, I don't think anyone noticed.
No.
Mission goals.
Keep drilling until target depth is reached.
87,000...
Or no.
8,759 meters.
Locate signal source.
Find out what happened to previous expedition for tomorrow.
Something wrong with vent?
Tell Bodon.
Cockpit vent.
Some numbers.
This is where we are.
Tic-tac-toe.
For tomorrow.
Strata, certificate of achievements.
Stepan Adebeco.
Oh, he's distinguished.
Okay.
Emergency.
Okay, guys.
Hold on, I'm going to take a photo of this.
801-641-882.
I took a photo of that.
Bodan has been losing teeth, which makes him even more
irritable than usual.
So those were not our teeth?
Okay, okay.
Other than that, the man seems to be keeping it together
better than the rest of us.
Speculating it might be because he has a family waiting for
him back home.
Something to keep him going.
Victor, that's us.
White rabbit sickness is hard on us all, but seems to be
hitting Victor harder than most.
Not surprising, sadly.
The signal seems intent on digging up the parts of the past
we'd prefer to forget.
And Victor was doing his best to forget even before the
mission.
Remarkable that he's still one of the nation's best
navigators, even when half drunk.
Still giving him some extra attention.
he's not alone.
Yosef.
That's the guy that's upstairs, no?
White rabbit.
Yeah, I was thinking radiation, right?
sickness, some sort of radiation, perhaps?
Yosef lives in his own little world, as usual.
He claims to be receiving instructions about the white
rabbit from a dead friend, which is never a good sign.
Getting near impossible to communicate with him about
anything other than the signal.
As long as I've known him, he's always been obsessive about
his work.
This seems different.
Perhaps he simply sees more than the rest of us.
It seems like our captain is like pretty...
Uh...
Sound of mind, at least.
Step on, step on.
Joints are acting up.
Eyesight seems to be deteriorating, and emptying the bladder
is more difficult than I'm remembering.
Remembering it's ever been.
Oh, no.
It's hard to pee?
This is the...
Why are we doing this?
What can be said, the white rabbit seems to want to remind
me of my age.
She is there, too, of course.
She always is.
that's a little who is she when can I mate her if I want to
yeah
see sometimes I turn my head and like it sounds like
someone's stepping you know but it's just me it's freaking
me out who is she are these flies oh no it's just dust Okay.
I like the symbols on here.
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
I need something to fix the vent.
Where does this go?
It doesn't say.
Oh, the cockpit.
Just kidding.
It does say.
But there's nowhere to put my...
Um, nowhere to put my cassette tape into.
I don't think this will work, but we could try.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Should we find a screw- Wait, there was a screwdriver
upstairs, no?
Yeah, I think there was one, right?
Because, uh...
This guy had one.
Right here.
Oh, you winked at it?
Thank you.
Yes, yes.
There's something else on the computer?
No inserted cassette.
Can I insert...
You?
It's just gonna tell me about myself, though, no?
Yeah.
What if I did the...
the what's it called oh wait are those cassettes no yes yes
and no oh I left the message one upstairs oh but I turned
off the power upstairs
maybe it's fine maybe it's fine Ooh, it's be- wait.
Oh, yeah.
I didn't notice the smoke before.
Okay, that seems kind of bad.
Flathead screwdriver.
Chipped, but still reliable.
The last line of defense holding the vessel together.
Yeah.
Lefty Lucy, lefty Lucy, lefty Lucy.
Vessel is off course.
Course correction required.
I know!
Lefty Lucy, lefty Lucy.
This actually kind of feels like mouthwashing it.
People were saying it gives that vibe.
Can I...
Oh, wow!
Okay.
Oh my god, there's a full like...
Cut screen.
I was cut...
Cutscene.
Whoa, okay.
Okay.
Oh.
Whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's very slow.
It's not even me, like it's the game.
What the heck is that?
Is that a plant?
This is a plant?
Is it actually the thing?
Is there gonna be something in here?
Let's step on, surely.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, completely dark!
I can't see anything!
Oh, the game just saved.
That's not a good sign, I think.
I'm really looking around, I see nothing.
I think I can walk again.
Uh.
This is where I came from.
It's just the tooth fairy heading to the sink.
You're so right!
Oh.
Insert.
Huh.
Hey.
Yeah.
Insert key to start engine.
Oh!
Key.
What's that say?
Throne 732.
And an angel descended upon the earth and wiped every tear
from their eyes.
Okay.
Anyway, where's the key?
Ignition key.
Input coordinates!
Oh, we're in here!
I'm gonna do navigating again!
Current course outdated.
Drill standby.
Why did that open by itself?
Wait somebody knocked, no?
Oh, it could have been the pipes from the door unlocking.
Like the, yeah.
The door going like, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
Unlocking, right?
No, that's it.
That's it.
What is this?
I keep seeing these little gums around.
Oh, geez.
Game has spooking me in a way that I have not felt in a
while.
you know what coordinates do we have to go to though
waypoint set yes left engine operational yes right engine
operational yes so everything is good we just all went a
little crazy and so now we don't want to work anymore input
coordinates this is all a lot okay hold on because there's
so many levers there's this lever there's this lever this
lever this key.
Insert cassette.
Is it me?
Incompatible.
What does it need to be?
This is up.
This is sideways.
This is another key.
Huh?
Ground down.
density chart.
Exceeding max speed risks overheating or drill collapse.
Oh, this is how you put in the coordinates!
But what do I put in?
I'm scared.
We know there's something around now.
Can you tell me?
Maybe...
These?
Oh, but it's only...
No.
I wonder if I have to go get that one cassette back.
Wait.
Is this where I came from?
Wait a second.
Wait.
Am I crazy?
Is this different now?
Sergei.
Yeah, it was a bit warm down though.
there.
Depth achieved.
3,042 meters.
July 14, 1954.
Elena.
The earth is not a foe.
She is a challenge.
Depth achieved.
4,287 meters.
Yeah, I don't recall these pictures.
The arrows and everything.
Alexei?
The deeper we go, the higher our nation's dance.
Depth achieved 4,904 meters.
You guys are all wimps.
We've gone past 6,000 meters.
What's the smiley for?
Oh, my...
What's all the arrows for?
I can't open any of these.
My mop?
Oh.
Whoa.
where are we what is this oh the brightest minds belong
below they're trying to send everybody to be moles in the
earth record uh-huh we're in school guide our nation through
the dark enlist as a navigator is this like my memory yeah
or something data, get coordinates.
Oh, yeah, I'm losing it a little bit, maybe.
Okay.
What is this?
Strata course correction exam.
This examination constitutes the final assessment prior to
navigator certification.
All responses are evaluated against strata operational
standards.
Successful completion grants operational clearance.
Make us all proud, Victor.
Good luck.
Yeah, I'm so sick with white rabbit.
Crazy.
According to the October Doctrine, when was the first step?
What is the first step?
I can't even read it.
I'm going to fail, Clash.
What is the first step in a course correction procedure?
Activate the ping lever to strike the tunnel walls and
gather raw seismic data.
I knew that.
I could have answered that in my sleep.
What must be done with raw echo data before it can be used?
Translate it into a visual terrain map through a decryptor.
After processing the echo data, how should the sonar arrows
be adjusted?
Um, beautifully, probably.
The coordinate setter arrows should be pointed towards the
least obstructed points on the screen.
Yeah, that's what I said.
After extracting coordinates from the sonar, how is the
course correction carried out?
Input the coordinates into the pilot, then steer towards the
target using the joystick.
What was that?
What was that sound?
Stuff.
How is the correct throttle RPM determined for drilling?
What is that?
Read the ground density from the decrypted data and match it
to RPM chart.
Score blank out of five.
Return completed exam to the front desk for evaluation.
I'm turning my sound down.
Minto, quick fact about digging holes.
Russia drilled a borehole reaching a vertical depth of
12,000 meters in the 70s.
It's likely behind you.
I think it is.
um she's right behind me isn't she okay do I need to return
my exam I like the birds it's
just the wind yeah yeah I'm scared I'm scared so we record
or process the data get the coordinates I have this whatever
this is for I guess this is the coordinates, right?
Something's gonna come at me, though.
Have you ever seen a living mole, Minto?
The animal?
I have!
I love moles!
The arrows are still telling me this way, so like, why would
I leave?
Wait, this is like the actual outside.
We are so losing it.
Okay.
I'm gonna be brave.
We got coordinates everybody!
Or something.
Back to my hole.
Back to being a little mole.
Insert?
Ready to record.
Seismic data found.
Pull lever to record.
Holy cow!
Okay, it did say seismic data.
Seismic data encoded.
Take out the cassette.
error data must be decrypted on the terminal this guy all
right press space yes yes yes I know all these I know all
this ghost echo detected artifact cross-band ghost echo how
did they how did they get into my new cafe and Hello!
Hello!
Ground density four.
A very spooky number.
I'm so- I wish I could shut the door!
Let me be locked in my hole, please.
Insert.
Okay.
What?
Oh, I then have to find, like, the one that has, like, the
lead.
okay okay I get I remember it was saying like you do this
we're like no obstructions or something right and then I'll
do this I'm such a good little mo I find no obstructions
okay then what then what though like that and then I in
again stick stick it in stick it in stick it in stick it in
stick it in stick it in stick it in stick it in stick it in
stick it in stick it in stick it in stick it in where do i
do with this information oh y28 x26 i'm kidding i'm a kidder
y28 26.
There we go!
Can I get rid of this panel so I can see?
Oh yeah.
Oh.
Oh, this way.
Whoa!
What does that mean?
Oh, here's the, here it is.
Alright.
Oh!
Thank you!
Thank you, Rezi, for the raid.
Hello, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Now what?
What did that do?
We're here?
Paperbacks, thank you, Dorgo, thank you!
The drill speed?
Well, um...
Oh, that's right.
I've addressed the RPM with the throttle by terrain density.
How am I supposed to know what the density is, though?
Ground density.
It doesn't say here.
Or does it?
Oh, it does.
Four.
So if it's four, we do 30 RPM.
And then I set that here.
We be digging.
Oh, well, thank you so much.
Make your first course correction.
Oh, we did it.
Oh, well, thank you so much for the whole thing.
I did it.
Course corrected.
Autopilot engaged.
Okay.
We're going down, down.
What's that sound?
What?
Wait, is it time for lunch?
I see, I hear the phone, but do you guys not hear the Dump,
Dump, Dump.
You guys don't hear that?
I'm a little spooked.
Oh, it's just the ship moving.
Oh, it's back to normal.
Wait.
Wait, I love it.
Okay, I get it.
It's not back to normal because where'd the door go to go to
the rec room?
And here?
Hello?
Oh, here.
Victor?
It's Herzenko.
Where are you?
Where is everyone?
There is something with us here on the vessel.
know where it came from.
I don't know what it wants.
Listen, Victor, listen to me.
I was right about the signal.
It reacts to us as we drill, as we get closer.
It's alive, Victor.
I know things don't seem good now.
We have to keep digging.
But first, come meet me in my dorm.
I have to show you what I've found.
We are on the brink of a discovery unlike anything mankind
has ever seen.
I just know
No, who was...
Be careful.
Oh!
Who was phone?
Something is...
Okay, when it said internal phone call, I was a little
stressed.
Luckily it was friend?
Maybe.
Be careful.
I'm freaked out.
I hope there's not, like, stealth in this game.
Guys, I have to sleep tonight.
Who is careful?
I don't know, but they freaking me out.
They're freaking me out.
E!
Oh, my God.
Guys, it's bad.
It's bad, bad.
is bad bad guys this is bad bad I'm freaked out for real I'm
hiding in the kitchen do I need to hide no I need to turn
the lights on upstairs though phone was dead guy by the way
no it wasn't it was it oh the I don't like the lights
actually it's a little too often you know what I mean oh
wait oh it won't let me do it oh shoot it actually won't let
me adjust this okay oh I'm so freaked out
oh oh no oh no no no no no no
no oh my goodness I can grab this now oh
no no no no it smiles it waits it wakes it lies it festers
it calls red means scary you guys who spilled the marinara
everywhere it wait it festers it lies it smiles and it can't
be that mean Here we go.
What the hell was that?
Survive the monster.
I did?
Was that the guy that...
Oh my gosh, that was scary.
Holy cow.
Breathe out.
You did well.
That was nothing but a creature of the past.
I'm afraid it gave up on your kind a long time ago.
I never did.
I wonder why you are here so far below the earth.
The signal's talking to us.
I suppose you are still looking for your son.
Oh!
My son?
Son, where are you?
Is this my apartment?
It's my home?
The Voss...
Oh, he is still here somewhere in this old painful memory of
yours.
You just have to find him again.
The Voss Talk Initiative, a sun that never sets.
The light of consciousness is the most precious thing any
citizen may own.
Never let go.
Disclaimer, must be kept cold.
Huh?
Nani?
Nangato?
Do we just sleep?
Oh, I thought...
I thought from here it looked like a little hand grenade.
I was like, yes, I sleep with my trusty hand grenade by my
side.
I noticed these flowers while I was running from the
creature.
I wonder what happens if you get caught.
Actually, I don't wonder.
I think I'm good.
I'm good.
The Institute Bank of the SPRN.
Notice of outstanding debt.
Oh, that's right.
They said they would forgive our debt, right?
Citizen Kaminsky.
The Institute notes that the total sum of your debt now
exceeds 30...
Is that a million?
I haven't never seen that many zeros before.
Encountered a fellow Ibu at the gas station.
No way.
39 million zev.
This letter serves as a reminder that we have the authority
to dispossess your citizenship status.
Should we see no change in your capacity to repay the
outstanding amount?
Yikes.
following is a summary of your recent significant bank
statements hospital no negative minus 2 million the Vostok
initiative minus 12 million did he like try to keep the
consciousness of his son so that his son would still be like
still Alive, kind of.
Vostok means East in Russian.
Well, thank you.
Relief for recent termination plus 78,000.
Kriya Oblast funerary arrangements, minus 1,000.
Relief for prolonged unemployment plus 45,000.
That's so sad.
He's just a grieve.
Even dad.
That's so sad.
September 1982.
Oh.
I didn't know grabbing that would do that.
Still asleep in the static.
Bring him to the TV.
Oh yes, it says the vote.
Oh yes, that's right.
Because it said it must be kept cold, right?
I wanted to see what was in our fridge.
Dang it.
Oh god, I can't see anything.
I don't like this.
The past lies buried down here, Victor.
But it doesn't have to be set in stone.
The past?
Your son can still be saved.
I can help you find what you seek.
And in the end, perhaps we can both find redemption.
Again, wake up for the second time.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, they seem nice.
My glasses, please.
Thank you.
Victor.
Oh, we've had a chance to consider what I said when we last
spoke.
I'm truly sorry, it's been so long.
I know it's easy.
Is the music getting a little like...
Nah, it's still a bop.
I know it's easy for others to talk about dark times and how
to make them go away.
What was that meme?
When dark times.
When...
Um, hold on.
I have to look up.
Oh, oh, you know.
You, when dark time, remember happy time.
Remember, what was it?
Who was it?
Yuka?
Yuka meme?
Yuka meme.
When dark time.
Please remember.
Always remember happy day.
even if you don't know the rest of it just remember always
remember happy day that's the big important message of it
it was the same with darn darina so many colleagues telling
me to make sure to get some sun as if that would bring her
back but i really don't think we should be calling that
number oh i don't think you should be calling that number I
know you want to cling on to hope but hope is not what
they're offering They want to take you somewhere that
doesn't exist a place that will never let you truly heal My
door is always open if you want to talk Stefan It's Stefan
Stefan They still got my smokes Oh I got my whole inventory
Oh
good morning strata What a lovely day Oh we're still
employee still 43 we're still civil status father wait
didn't that didn't that say divorced before criminal history
yes wait didn't it actually say something different it said
divorced before yeah yeah yeah yeah
little is is the creature my son did you do this i like the
taped on fake window to the wall
oh my god he wait he did he had legs before for take the
cassette you will need it
Yes, yeah, it's the guy.
My dear friend, let me tell you something I think would
surprise you.
Ever since I was first exposed to the signal, I've been
hearing your voice again.
This is a strange and wonderful thing in itself.
But the things...
Oh yeah, it was Hurt Senko.
Sorry, I can't stop you running.
Here, Hurt Senko was the guy on the phone, no?
Okay, okay, okay.
our geologist man right strange and wonderful thing in
itself but the things you revealed to me about the signal
are stranger and more wonderful still you told me to
interpret the frequency as brain waves it's not fickle or
random but an expression of something almost like a mind
only one more vast and complex than anything we've ever
encountered before you also told me that the the signal can
be trapped.
Hercenium.
Okay, sure.
Seems to stay...
Oh, just gonna name it after yourself.
Sure, sure.
I didn't mention cannibalism, did I?
I don't think so.
Hercenium seems to stabilize the signal when it passes
through the crystal structure, like a beam of light
suspended by a prism.
The two things are clearly linked.
Midsenium.
I like the ring of it.
Well, you did now.
No, it doesn't count.
It doesn't count.
The two things are clearly linked.
That much I can figure out even without you.
Oh my god, wait.
Voice in the head.
Telling him what to do.
FK and the coffee.
Clear as day.
You guys, this is York.
Yosep.
Heard said co.
Y-O-R-K-Y-O-Y-O-S-P-YORK.
You hear that, Zach?
Yeah, there's a York in his name!
Huge.
Now there is talk about aborting the mission, and I feel
like I may be the only one who realizes how close we are to
uncovering something truly momentous.
I so very much missed the correspondence we had.
I know you would have understood.
Yours truly, Yosef Horsenko.
Was this, this was not self-afflicted, was it now?
It's 9 a.m.
Source of massive blackouts discovered.
Signal found by Dr. Horsenko.
Sorry, one second.
There we go.
You've cracked this case wide open.
Yeah.
I'm afraid to talk.
take this because i'm a you got anything good in there i
could put on a new uniform
oh difficult to tell well he makes it sound like it was it
was self-inflicted but the legs hmm And the arms...
His arms were cut off.
His legs were cut off.
His fingers were cut off.
His eye was taken out.
His nose was taken out.
His head was bashed in.
His neck was cut.
Alright, I'm gonna grab that.
I...
Attention, no...
valid waypoint.
Acquire updated coordinates from the laboratory.
Okay.
What's in here?
Nothing.
Dang, the blood even got through the door.
My man's is always working with rocks.
So we're gonna be going through each person?
Is that what's gonna happen?
The blood is still all over the place though.
This This game is freaky.
We're at 7,423 meters, you guys!
And it's November 10th!
Yeah.
Okay.
So we have a new message, maybe?
Yes, we do.
Communication, cassette.
These are kind of fun.
The cassettes are kind of fun.
understand the iron lung vibes of this very much.
Mouthwashing too, I get it, I get it.
So far this is super interesting.
Attention, no valid waypoint.
I know, I know, I know.
Maria here.
We at Surface Control had our first moment of joy since the
Matroshka incident when you completed the course correction.
like actively monitoring us still.
Thank you for keeping our hopes alive.
Now for the bad news.
Oh, man.
Our systems have lost track of the signal again.
What?
Yeah, iron lung because of the isolation, mouthwashing due
to having no idea what happened.
Exactly, exactly.
You'd think something that has caused so much havoc up here
would be easier to find.
I'm aware that Dr. Hurtzenko is responsible for interpreting
the signal data do they know do they know but it's been a
disturbingly long time since we've received any data at all
from his lab that's why they want us to go to the lab so
that we can got it we gotta go oh okay this is a one-man job
now oh my god you could call it a hail mary a project hail
mary A wink-wonk.
A wink-wonk.
So when's lunch?
It's a one-man jaw, baby.
Where's Rocky?
We just got chased by him.
It was a maze, a maze, a maze!
I refuse to accept the worst.
But you need to make a new recording, even if Hurtzenko is
unable to do so himself.
Otherwise, you'll be digging blindly.
for tomorrow.
Okay, lady, if you want it done so badly, you do it.
Huh?
We'll keep my music on because it's fun and excitable.
Makes me happy.
So, only Hartsenko was the guy that said no to a boarding.
Everybody else was like, I'm out of here.
No active waypoint is set.
Okay.
I'm looking around to see if anything else is kind of like,
you know, Any new information's have been?
No.
The body's gone?
Oh yeah, we saw him upstairs.
We also got chased real good by him.
It was fun.
It was a good time.
We have fun here on the ship, right guys?
Right, everybody?
Is this on?
It wasn't before no cassette inserted What if I insert this
guy's cassette the turquoise one?
What's it say found a geologist dorm the teal shell is
scratched with frantic ineligible notes.
Ooh freaking Wait, I kind of want to read about him.
Yeah, let's read about him a little bit Yosef Hortenko age
20?
Wait, I'm sorry.
Wait, does that say 20?
Does that say 20?
Wait, guys, I'm so sorry.
So basically, uh, my, I still have ear infection in my right
ear, so I've been wearing my headphones, my big ear
headphones, but I've been wearing them half of my ears and
they're starting to hurt.
So I'm going to, uh, attempt to find my other headphones
amongst all my stuff.
one second it should be just somewhere around
one second uh oh
distant monkey i'm looking around hold on i'm gonna check i
don't see them in my suitcase so i'm gonna go look away look
look around real quick one second
i feel like i feel like they're in this bag but oh oh my
gosh yes i found them
back to game
about to go to bed analog horror stream is this the analog
horror stream I don't know I just saw a ghost in scary
sounds where'd you see a ghost where'd you see a ghost me
go back into my ear oh thank goodness
that guy was 20 I don't know if I believe that that was a
rough 20 I mean he's a really I mean, you know.
Guy has a lot of stress on his shoulders.
Civil status, unmarried, citizenship, priority.
Criminal history, no.
Oh, 28.
But still, yeah.
Responsibilities, geologists, perform signal recordings,
evaluate signal data, collect rare earth samples.
Fun.
So we're going.
Uh, we're going right over here.
Here into the laboratory?
Open up.
Open up, baby.
Ah, yes.
Smells like science.
off the light.
Why does it say that?
Wait, why does it say that?
Okay, hold on.
We gotta read things before we do that.
Wired...
Okay.
Wired raw reader circuit to screen.
Place crystal on circuit to activate.
Her sentium crystal seems to trap frequency.
Signal exposure leaves imprint on retina.
Need room to be dark.
align retinal mark with chart that new science smell oh yeah
he's done so much science in here I'm about to do so much
science in here signal how signal handling procedure
objective convert signal data into a usable waypoint
restriction signal data destabilizes vessel systems on
contact approved method A tune radio transmitter to correct
signal frequency.
Record the signal onto a cassette.
Insert cassette into navigation system to process
coordinates.
Important standard strata cassettes will fail under signal
load.
Use instead neural storage cassettes.
Oh, like the things that my son is in.
Designed to carry unstable cognitive data compatible with
signal structure.
Put it back.
Wait, what am I supposed to do with this?
Wait, wait, wait.
Put it back?
Wait.
Look at this invisible cube.
Uh, wait.
Uh, I was supposed to...
Oh!
This is my light, Victor.
At least what remains of it.
Oh my gosh, I'm seeing colors.
Follow it, and it will lead you through the darkness.
Do I record this, or?
I'm not sure what.
Put that in there.
I'm staring.
It says don't stare at it directly, huh?
Oh wait, I have to look at- I have to turn off the light.
Give me numbers!
Wait.
How am I supposed to know?
17... 120?
17 120 maybe
tune all right I told you guys I'm good at this I'm so good
at uh science and stuff so then we go put this back into our
other machine all right should I turn this off or whoa whoa
whoa whoa
What is that sound?
Now where do I put this into?
Here?
No?
Was there a...
Did it say a thing to put it into?
Oh, there's an X on the floor where you're supposed to
stand.
Another fuse!
I got one, I got one!
Uh...
Have you tried blowing on the car?
Designed to carry Tune transmitter, we did that, record,
insert, it's a navigation system to process coordinates.
Where is that?
Is that not...
This is not navigation?
The computer in here?
Oh, maybe here?
Oh.
Where is it?
Did I leave it?
Wait.
Where did it put it?
Oh, here it is.
I'm stupid.
Sorry.
There we go.
files to commit system requires three vectors of file type
XYZ I'm
doing it I'm doing it so stinking impatient okay is that it
enter to push oh push the files pushing pushing we're
pushing we're pushing I'm ulting I'm pushing upload the
Waypoint data.
Lock in.
Attention, vessel is off course.
Course correction required.
You're so annoying.
So, okay.
Wait, how do I do this again?
I think, okay.
Wait, before we do this, though, let's put in the fuse.
We got another fuse thing.
I...
Oh, we don't...
We have to go into engine, eventually.
So I imagine we'll want the fuse for that.
Then we turn this to three.
Then one, three, six in the number after.
Then the green.
Then the bling.
Okay.
Freaky.
Scary.
So we have seen only one body.
Out of...
Three.
we have a little couple's corner here in the engine room?
Maybe?
Did you read the message you got before?
What does that mean?
What message I got before?
Okay.
Hello.
All right.
Success.
Oh, that's right.
I have to decrypt it.
I'm turning so slowly because I'm afraid.
The one upstairs.
Huh?
The message I got in the very early of the morning?
Yeah, that was the first thing we did.
Ground density 271.
All right.
All right, all right, all right.
Do it right there.
Nice and easy.
There we go.
Oh my God, I'm doing it.
Gosh, stop backseating me.
85, 35.
I'm doing it, I'm doing it!
And then, oh, that's right.
Well, the ground density was what?
2.71.
So...
Oh, geez.
About 60?
59?
I don't want to do math.
Don't make me.
How do I do this again?
Oh, this, here we go.
Beep, beep.
Oh, what a funny sound.
Uh, then I, what was it?
Six, wait.
It's like about here-ish.
Right?
A little more?
What?
You sunk my battleship.
I'm so good.
the game message received beep beep beep beep do I have to
center it but or do I have to press something wait I'm
confused I don't remember what to do here
yeah sorry guys it was acting up what am I supposed to do
now 62
was it it It's 2.71, so that would be closer to this, no?
It'd be in between 2.6 and 3.
So maybe it'd be, like, closer to 50?
Like that?
Between 54 and 62?
Closer to 60?
Well, that's where it just was, and it didn't do anything.
I'm actually not doing this.
It just... Oh!
Oh!
Ah, no.
There we go.
Okay, we just had to be a little...
Oh, the game just saved.
We just had to be a little...
A little patient.
Who's calling this time?
October 1980.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, wow.
Oh, put in my 50 Zs.
That's a lot of sleep.
I'm ready.
Uh.
Oh, my son!
1979.
Oh, the Vostok Initiative.
Eight.
Ugh, I'm not gonna remember this.
Bobe!
Me too stream on my birthday.
Happy birthday!
Let's see.
Oh my gosh.
Payment due 30 days from issue?
A son that never sets.
Wait, that's kind of messed up because, like, it's his son.
But also, a son that never sets, you know?
Like, the person's consciousness stays alive.
But it's also his son.
So his son will never leave him.
Neural cassette, 20 million zees.
Oh my god.
Hospital site deployment, inscription procedure,
preparation, and custodial packaging.
Vostok makes no medical claims.
Interpretation and meaning are left to those who receive the
cassette.
Man, that's a lot of money.
What's this?
Parking check.
Central Hospital 12.
Do you think our son like just died or something?
Petro.
Ugh, I couldn't take a second picture of this kid.
Oh, holy cow.
Petro.
Hello father.
Nevriska.
Socialist People's Republic of Nevriska.
all right
just looking around real quick is that our car i could hold
on hold on let me grab something from my hold on a second i
already put my quarter in please i just need one thing hold
on i don't want anybody to take you know this is my call i
don't want anyone please can i just get some real quick out
of my I just can't believe this.
Alright, alright, hold on.
I got the phone number.
It was...
Eight...
Two, seven, three...
Six, four, zero, nine.
You have reached Vostok Continuity Services.
Thank you for taking this step.
Before we proceed, please remember.
Preservation is not an act of denial.
It is an act of care.
A neural cassette has been issued to a registered name.
How do they know?
Please enter the cassette identification number associated
with its name and then press number.
They're like forcing us to do this.
It's kind of messed up.
No account is registered under that ID Wait what?
Was that not the cassette?
Oh, that's the invoice, my bad Oh, 51, 51 I'm dumb, sorry, I
just It's been a long day I have this idea Idea associated
with the name Petro Petro If this is correct, press 1.
If not correct, press 2.
What if I press 2?
If English is not the language you speak, press 3.
Find out.
Oh, the game...
Oh, a neural cassette has been issued to a registered name.
Oh, okay.
It just makes you do the number thing again.
Okay.
Petrol!
I've satiated my curiosity.
It's correct.
Thank you, Kaminsky, for registering with Vostok.
The records indicate that the payment has not yet been
finalized and requires your registration consent.
This call serves as verification.
To proceed, we will ask you to confirm some details.
Enter the age of the person associated with this record.
then press number oh shoot how old is he uh january 2nd 19th
i have to do math okay hold on uh january 1974.
today is 1986.
It has been verified.
Please enter the hospital identification number where the
person is currently located.
Uh...
12?
I feel like they're lowering my guard here.
I'm getting too comfortable with this scenario.
Information is correct.
I previously stated that the person's last confirmed happy
memory occurred on their birthday.
Aww.
Please enter the date of this memory and date, date, month,
month, year, year for me.
1979, so it was January 2nd, 79.
Oh, one.
Oh, shoot.
I messed up.
Uh.
What was it?
O2?
O1, 79.
Thank you, this date is correct.
How would you know?
Purification is complete.
All required details have been confirmed.
The total amount due is 39 million ZEV.
To confirm payment, press 1.
To cancel this request, press 2.
Payment has been authorized.
Make the Vostok Bank transaction.
Debt.
I got.
The funds will be withdrawn from your bank account.
Your account is now in debt and may be subject to citizen
review.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
During an on-site visit, a personal recording was collected
from you.
This recording will now be played back.
Static and whistling.
Me?
Talk?
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm not...
I'm not good with words.
I feel like I should remember some special moment to tell
you about.
But I can't.
I don't know where one memory ends and the next one begins.
It's all just...
him.
All these things I want to teach him.
All these things I want him to experience.
Just everything.
Everything struggling.
in the background.
Puffs in the background.
Hey.
Ooh.
Shhh.
I know.
I know it hurts.
Puffs in the background.
What happened to him?
It's okay.
Daddy is here.
I wonder if he has the white rabbit sickness or something.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh, I'm crying.
I just don't want to give up.
I just want to be the kind of father who tries.
Who keeps trying until there's nothing left to try.
End of recording.
This is so sad!
Thank you for sharing that with us.
Due to the subject's critical condition, the day scheduled
for the inscription procedure is tomorrow.
These cutscenes are crazy.
Post-procedure documentation will be finalized
automatically.
Cassette retrieval instructions will be issued within the...
Something.
But I'm sorry I didn't catch it.
I'm truly sorry you had to go through that again.
Set the signal.
But you need to...
Remember, why you have to keep digging.
Holy cow!
Oh my god!
Are these any different, I wonder?
No.
These are all the same.
So...
Now we are able to go into the engine.
I guess this is doing its thing.
Oh, current course outdated.
So it's when?
I fixed it, no?
What the heck?
Heck, I fixed it, no?
Wait, where's my...
Oh, here.
Oh, I have to do it again.
I guess?
so the white rabbit is using us to reach them with the sun
as a pretext that appears to be the potential case okay so
this isn't opening okay so we gotta do this again I think um
I don't know where I need to I think it's the same spot so
maybe not yeah I'm standing on the X Let's walk around
somewhere, see if something else has changed around here.
What does it say?
The vessel is off course, check diagnostics in the cockpit
located on the deck.
It looked the same, though, no?
Uh, currently we have only gotten little clues to...
Of course, course correction required.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just steer?
Maybe?
No, it says...
input the coordinate so we're 7,423 though how exciting wait
a second there's a second thing here and the angel spoke the
earth shall give up those who are asleep in it there will be
no more death or mourning or crying or pain so this okay let
me let me try this one more time because this has no data on
it, right?
Oh, pull lever to record.
Or yes, it does, maybe.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Recording successful.
Okay.
Then this.
Into here.
Oops.
I do it every time.
I must encrypt.
I'm encrypting.
Okay.
And space.
La la la la la.
Alright.
Ground density updated.
Put you in here.
La la la.
Okie dokie.
I love how easy and convenient it is to have just a very
open point, you know?
A little over.
A little.
Wait, can I?
Nice.
Alright.
La la la la la la la la la la.
Like 18.
18Y69X.
18Y.
Gosh, I'm the best in the biz, guys.
To do this, apparently.
I'm the best in the biz.
Okay, and it was a 345.
So...
Let's say, like, 40, closer to 40.
Maybe, like, even, like, 47.
All right.
My joystick.
I'm piloting the submersible.
Hey!
Critical engine error.
Um, that's a toll.
Put it back in.
Attention, engine failure detected.
Immediate repair required.
Oh, oof.
Why won't this open?
Yeah!
Oh, not the check engine light on.
That's so awkward.
Internal!
Can you read me?
Step on?
Bodon here, please answer.
Bodon!
Victor.
Of course it's here.
I'm doing my job!
Don't say a word.
Just show.
Shut up.
I haven't said anything.
I told them from the start.
I said it during the prep.
I said it to Stepan's face.
If we bring you with us, then the mission is doomed.
You're poison, Victor.
That's what you are.
You sit up in that cockpit pretending you're in control.
While the rest of us burn in hell.
down here.
Katarina is waiting for me.
Lillia and Vera are waiting for me.
I have everything to lose.
All you have is that bullshit cassette full of fake
memories.
I'm taking the engines apart.
We're stopping here.
This mission is over.
How do you expect to go back up then?
Don't come down here.
Don't even effing think about trying to stop me.
Or I'll put a screwdriver through your Still?
Just stay up there, dig your own grave for all I care.
You seem good at that.
Dang!
Wait, how do you expect to go home if you do that, Bodak?
Uh oh.
We're going a little crazy again, guys.
Rup-ro.
Petals of white, cover fields, flowing green.
But where is Stefan, though?
Where is he?
We haven't seen him yet.
Here we go.
I'm coming down, Bodan.
You better not get me.
I have a screwdriver, too, actually.
Let's see who gets who first.
Mine's still covered in blood.
It's gotten a good taste.
Okay.
It's gotten a real good taste for blood, buddy.
Is that him?
What's in here?
We poipolkasset.
Anybody down here?
Why is this...
This place is a giant...
What the heck?
This place is huge!
What's up?
this.
November 2nd, fixed an issue with the engine filters.
Right one breaks when under too much strain.
Spoke to the pilot about it.
Weird MFR.
Weird Mint Phantom.
Didn't miss the stream.
Welcome!
Who screws who?
November 4th, right engine filter keeps breaking, keeping an
inventory on hand here in the shed for now.
Guest Strata dug up the first junk they could find for this
mission.
that idiots this bodine seems very like a pleasant man
November 5th piece of shoot piece of shit filter broke again
down to one spare now it'll have to do keep having
nightmares always about Lillia and Vera miss them so goddamn
much November 7th this mission was one big mistake from the
start things go missing everyone acts like lunatics the
pilot most of all me what's wrong okay okay okay okay i'm
not i bet my life he is risking this entire mission with
that insane cassette of his if adamenko is too much of an
idiot to steer this ship straight then i'll do it myself
guys i'm so sorry i have to go to the little ghosty's room
i'll be right back i'm so sorry i'll be right back i don't
want to get jump scared and get you know, have a surprise
ectoplasm come out.
Anyway, I'll be right back.
Ducky.
Ducky, so sorry for the wait.
Thank you for the super dad.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Alright, let's keep going.
Let's keep going, baby.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Oh, that's okay.
There we go.
Okay.
all right all right um i'm not gonna get screwed i will do
the screwing uh we need a key here before we go into the
depths what else we got in here something flammable amazing
why does this feel like a hiding spot wait oh i took that
whatever that is.
I guess I'll need it eventually.
I'm sure it will require it in due time.
For moral support.
Yes, yes, probably, probably.
Very good, very good.
Let's keep going.
Why are all the screens frapped?
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Oh, wee.
Okay, I don't think we heard...
Oh, geez.
Oh, uh-oh.
The door.
The screwdriver won't fit.
Ah, yada, ni-ga!
Yam it up!
Another guy to chase us later.
Why wait?
Why chase us now?
I dare you.
Get up!
Wait, are those his intestines?
Oh, there's even more.
Bodan?
You called?
You rang?
Seems pretty bad.
Don't worry, buddy.
I'll replace the fan.
I'm one man show here guys everybody remember I'm so good at
my job project Hail Mary amazing amazing amazing engine fan
engine in do I be the okay is that it I guess it's fine it's
not moving anything
over here what
is that sound though.
God is coughing.
Oh, the screwdriver I screwed back in.
Oh, yeah, I forgot that I didn't have it, like, in my hand
anymore.
Righty-tidy.
Wait, I'm going lefty, aren't I?
Wait.
Yeah, I'm going to the left.
This isn't how that works.
Okay.
Huh.
The game is broken.
Okay, he's still there.
Is it righty?
Is that righty?
Now, what's wrong over here?
Awesome.
Nice little setup you got going on here, Bowdoin.
Oh, whoa.
Uh, off the charts.
Uh, yep.
Very good.
And something over here.
Great place to get your ankles grabbed.
We're still going in.
There's more?
Oh my god.
Wee!
There's cigarettes in here!
Another fuse!
Oh.
Uh.
Well, let me grab it, please.
Thank you.
Uh.
Do I have to go find one or...
Right.
Gotcha.
Don't you already have one?
No, I put that...
Wait.
No, I already put...
I put that on the engine thing.
I did, I did.
I think we just have to fill...
Okay, still there.
Yeah, see, I don't have it anymore.
Unless...
Alright.
What is that?
nothing oh no it's not nothing oh it is nothing thank it no
please it won't oh i hate when it okay sorry guys i have to
it will only let you go forward
sorry unless i have to go take one of the fuses but we'll go
check that storage room first
no backing out.
Never quit.
Something, something.
Quitters never what?
Never back down, never what?
Back down!
Oh, where did I get this guy from?
Okay.
Wait a second.
Whack.
Whack it, whack it, whack it, whack it.
No?
Hmm.
Any fuse in here?
that I happen to miss?
Seems like a no.
Oh, man.
Do I really have to take it?
No!
With a steamy pipe!
You're right.
But that still doesn't fix our fuse issue.
Hurry!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Don't linger.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
The game is backseeding me for real.
To remain still is to be buried.
Whoa.
Oh, we're going crazy, crazy again.
Okay.
i mean we knew that because of the flowers and all but yikes
okay uh
oh god so scary
let's grab
engine failure yeah yeah yeah i know okay i'm gonna take it
from this room once we don't have this room anymore.
It's gonna be dark.
We gotta go.
Oh, I'm scared.
Minto, I'm a bit confused.
Okay.
We are seeing trees.
Can we even take it?
Maybe?
Okay.
We got it.
Oh, it's...
They're back to being broken again.
Okay.
Oh, why is it so dark?
Wait, why is it so dark?
Wait.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, look.
I've lost?
Wait, I've lost?
This is where I came from, or...
Yeah.
So we go this way.
Why is it so dark?
Is this different?
I didn't reconfigure the fuse box.
Oh.
Wait, who was what?
Wait, you guys saw somebody?
There was a person?
Wait, there was a man.
Oh, I didn't see it.
Wait, what do you guys mean there was a man?
there was somebody wait but this area is lit up so actually
it should be fine oh god I don't want to go back up there
it's dark
oh my god I missed the spooky I
I totally missed him my bad Also, it's a little hard to see
if my screen is like kind of small.
But where was he?
Oh my gosh.
This game is kind of scary.
This is pretty scary.
It's pretty, pretty freaking scary.
I'm a little spooked.
More than a little.
I'm pretty spooked.
What does that
sound?
We're back here.
All right, so let's go do the fuse and the uh The pipe thing
Okay, he's still here very good If not who then who was
phone If not him then who was phone
Okay, no, no
Maybe it's fine
What is that?
What's all that noise?
What was that?
It's gotta be the pipe, you guys.
It's the pipe.
Don't even fret.
Prepare the engine.
That'll do.
Okay, the game saves.
Oh, gosh.
Attention.
Vessel engine is Once again, operational.
New course correction is required.
Okay, let me get there.
One man job.
I'm scared.
Don't get me!
Actually, I'm gonna be the one to get the ankles.
Should I grab...
Did I leave the wrench here?
I did.
Maybe I grab it again.
Oh, it won't let me.
Okay, just kidding.
Okay.
But it's operating at a proper state.
All right.
Who did this to you?
Wait, is that another screwdriver?
Screwdrivers are tools.
They are not weapons.
Back up, up, up we go.
I feel like this game is longer than how it feels.
Does that make sense to you guys?
Like, I feel like we're...
Oh, be careful.
It is waking up.
What's that mean?
I'm stressed.
I'm stressed a little bit.
I'm not gonna lie.
Pretty stressed.
Wait, this is different.
What's happening?
Wait.
Hold your screwdriver.
You're so right.
It's waking up.
Did you have your coffee?
I haven't had my...
Don't talk to me until I've had my coffee.
Oh, gosh.
I'm stressing.
Okay.
No.
What was that?
I'm going in circles in circles.
Wait.
There's nothing here.
I can't.
You guys are seeing a guy?
What is that?
No, I didn't see the guy.
There was a shadow.
mine right oh gosh i'm so scared did
i miss a turn or uh take the cassette hurry this guy he's
gonna they're gonna yell it they're gonna
what's happening Oh, shoot.
Oh.
There was a guy.
Take the cassette.
Hurry.
Run.
Run like hell.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Oh, uh, wait.
Where am I?
Oh, shoot.
He's right behind me.
An error has occurred.
I couldn't see them where I...
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Awesome.
Great place to start.
I love it, love it, love it, love it, love it, love it, love
it, love it, love it, love it.
Oh, shoot.
Can I grab it again?
Thank you.
Where is the...
Oh, here.
Oh, my God.
Ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew,
ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew.
Oh, my God, oh my God, oh my God.
Door 311!
Door 311.
door 311 where where is this oh my gosh what I'm just going
oh $2.97 oh my god oh my god where
is door 311
oh it's 316 sure 313 311 go go go go go go go go I went out
of this I went out of this!
No!
Oh my god.
It's a cutscene.
Yeah, kick him in the...
Did
everybody win right at it?
Holy cow.
Phew.
Is it still coming after me?
Insert key, start engine.
Enter key!
You are to overcome it.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
God, that was so freaky.
That was tense.
Holy shoot.
Oh my god.
my god everything everything in me was was tense i think
earlier i was like i sure hope there's no chase scenes oh no
i said stealth scenes never mind that monster is how i feel
when getting this this game is freaky scary the foot sounds
every just seeing him down the hallway turn it around, run
it around!
Alright.
Okay.
Let's get back at it, everybody.
Was this the 69?
Yeah.
69 and
18.
I think that's exactly what I had before.
Actually.
There's a lot of sound going on, huh?
Weird.
Okay.
Input coordinates, that's what I did.
Did I do the right ones?
X69.
Oh, oops, oops, oops, oops.
18.
There we go.
The game was like, no dummy.
No dummy.
We're getting closer to the signal, everyone.
Maybe.
All right.
All right, and it was 3.45.
So that's like 45, maybe?
We'll see if this goes good.
Oh, it's free!
All right, very cool.
But the game just saved.
Where are we now?
Oh, elevator.
It's not letting me click on any of these, actually.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, it does.
Just kidding.
I'm going to two?
This drill has an elevator.
We are living in luxury.
Honestly.
Why is the game?
Oh.
Golly.
Floor one.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh.
No.
Oh, who said hospital 666?
Who said that?
I'm sweating.
Oh, I have a feeling, I have an inkling that it doesn't
matter what floor we picked.
But it could have been literally any single one.
Calamity Strikes Nation.
11th April.
That was...
That was the...
Oh, the date that was flashing.
11th April.
early morning, the first of an ongoing series of earthquakes
struck Oh, Niz-Nig, your Niz-Niz-Groad.
The event had led to several power plants failing in the
city center.
Like, yeah, your guess is as good as mine.
Seriously.
yeah ask Matara power plants failing the city center is at
the time of writing ravaged by countless fires more recent
reports also indicate that nearly all types of electronics
in the city have been rendered unusable
authorities have yet to comment on if this is a natural
phenomenon or some kind of coordinated attack the seemingly
ever escalating nature of the has however already led to
some dubbing it the matroshka incident so this is the
beginning of the signal
basically have you lost someone to lose a loved one is the
deepest wound a person can carry the world is cruel we
learned that far too early niche niche it's okay it's all
right i don't need to i don't need to know what is how to
pronounce it but thank you guys thank you but it does not
have to end here through revolutionary neuroarchival
technology the Vostok initiative offers a final chance to
preserve what matters most using our state of the art memory
cassettes a human consciousness can be transferred moments
before biological death a voice of memory a presence
preserved so you never truly have to say goodbye and perhaps
one day you may even speak again are we going to be haunted
by our son He's gonna be, like, chasing after us and stuff.
Oh, it's really dark in here.
Let's go this way.
Emergency notice confidential.
If you hear a patient who has been confirmed to be deceased,
speak.
Do not under any circumstances listen to what they are
saying.
It's pronounced Shagohod.
It's a ghost in the machine!
That's freaky, that's freaky, that's really, really freaky!
The Vostok Initiative, a sun that never sets.
The light of consciousness is the most precious thing any
citizen may own.
Yeah, that's the same flyer we had.
Oh good, we have a map.
What a snorer.
Is that where we're going?
out with that guy?
Oh, my God.
Where are we?
Okay, I see.
Hospital 12 Children's Ward.
Oh, I need to go to 3-11, don't I?
Wait, I don't see a 3-11.
It's not marked.
yeah what 311 yeah
yeah I guess over by 310 the unmarked one that's my guess as
well but there's a couple unmarked ones but I imagine it has
to be the one next to 310 if that even exists If this is a
stealth section, I'm gonna scream and rage quit the game.
Please don't.
Missing 411, 411.
Mental rage.
My smokes.
Stop snoring!
No, no, you got this.
this is this is like okay so I go through what would be the
easiest way maybe at the first intersection we turn right
and get get to 314 and go then go up what camera is this
facing though right it must be the one in this top right
corner because it's not the one right here or is it is it
wait that might be facing wait there might be a guy on that
thing right now right wait a second
oh invisible enemy just gets better and better just gets
better and better how did we avoid I guess he wasn't there
until we came back here or something, probably.
Alright.
All we can do is go, I guess.
Anything on here?
I don't even know if I need to do this.
Oh my gosh, it's so dark.
Did I reach the end?
Do I go this way now?
I can't move.
Wait.
Huh?
Maybe he's chill?
Honestly, probably he's really chill.
It wouldn't let me go back anymore.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Uh, let's go check it out again.
Is he patient zero of the signal?
my man oh three
okay I'm okay I don't see any other guys I guess we go to
the static TV and all right let's try it out that
helps kind of oh Oh, nice, nice.
Maybe?
Maybe not nice.
Well, we don't particularly like this, do we now?
Oh,
I saw that.
I can't tell if this is like a stealth section or not.
You know what I mean?
Of course.
Classic.
And the teeth.
Wait, 3-11 is right here.
I guess I'll I can't quite remember where the cameras were
at do all of these open okay
so here's the TV
duck my favorite oh no he's
right behind me isn't he guys I think He's right behind me.
Oh, he left?
Wait, I can't move, actually.
Oh, there we go.
That's why.
Eee!
Oh.
Oh, he left a little thing for us.
I think we should leave.
The Cornerstone.
Directorate Board Question Strata.
Maria Damchenko.
of the once dominant mining and energy conglomerate Strata
has been summoned by the Directorate Board.
Demchenko is to answer questions about a possible connection
between the so-called Matroshka incident and the M12
mission, a Strata-sponsored expedition that launched earlier
this month.
The expedition was the first mission of its kind undertaken
by Strata in over nine years.
Yeah.
little guy the little monster was like extra extra read all
about it a second expedition has now been proposed this time
to be led by veteran geonaut stepan adamenko the goal of
this expedition is said to be to investigate why the m12
lost contact with the surface though strata has claimed to
have no hope in finding their crew still alive the music is
so scary you guys
This game is kind of scary, you guys.
This game?
Kind of freaky.
What's...
Oh, how am I?
Um...
Do you hear other...
Where are the footsteps coming from?
Yeah, right?
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm walking.
I'm going back to the first room we went to.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's so scary.
Oh, I'm so creeped out right now.
Oh, I'm so creeped out.
Ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew.
Let's see if another number appeared.
Oh my god, I still hear him.
Oh, wait.
That's 3.11.
Okay, so yeah, we go to 3.11 now, right?
Yeah, that's definitely 3.11.
Why is he running?
Oh, it's a 7.
You're right.
It is a 7 here.
Okay.
Yeah, we gotta go into 3.11.
Okay, alright.
So.
Three, something, seven.
It might be a one, yeah, but I think the game wants us to
probably do it properly.
Oh, holy cow!
Is this my place?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Grab the valuables!
Oh my gosh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
All right, we will check just in case.
It's gotta be probably 317, but whatever.
Well, we never know.
That's why we double check.
Oh my gosh, my computer.
Are you okay?
Okay, it's not that hot.
It's not as hot as the other day.
What just left?
Oh my god.
That's not for you to play in.
He's right in front of me!
Um...
The devs are evil, right?
Do I go to 317 then or...
Do I put that on the elevator?
Oh, he's right.
He gave me a key.
Thank you.
We have, like, lost it, lost it.
I think he gave me a key to the room.
Okay.
All right, let's go.
Okay,
I don't have an inventory.
317 was to the right.
And all the way down, I think?
Yeah.
Right over here.
Did that work?
Oh, Victor, no wonder you...
What happened to her?
But you still refuse to believe death would be the end.
Instead, you set him free.
He's in a full body cast!
Oh, my God!
Do you think it was the Matroshka incident that happened?
Or, like, maybe he was crushed or...
The little ball!
He was so proud that his dad was.
Oh my god.
Wait, I have to do this.
This is messed up.
Oh, the burn.
Oh, that's right.
We did go through the burning building.
You're right.
Oh, well, that's what I mean, though.
It could have been from the, what's it called?
The burning building could have been from the...
They said that the Matroska incident like caused earthquakes
and...
and had it where like you know all the power outage and
stuff and everything yeah so it could be that we joined this
because you know we were a good mole but also because me
window window streams no
because uh yeah it said fires in the city center exactly
exactly what the heck okay so what's the During the moment
of passing, there is a change of exactly 21 grams in a
patient's weight.
This has been theorized as being the soul leaving the body.
I think these guys have something to do with it.
This reminds me of SpongeBob.
I was thinking that too.
Every morning I wake up.
I break my arms and then I go to sleep and I break my legs.
My bones are made of glass.
It is of utmost importance that this moment is captured by a
neural recorder.
Euthanasia is therefore needed to ensure the recording and
the patient's moment of passing are synchronized.
Do I have to turn these off?
Everything's on.
Cardiac support.
Respiratory.
What if I miss it?
My son.
What have they done to you?
He'd be sucking on that tube.
I'm sorry.
No, this is serious.
This is serious.
Okay.
the recorder.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, don't... Don't leave me yet, son.
Oh, that was the respiratory unit.
You might need that part.
Gotta cope somehow.
Right!
I just turned them off.
Oh!
Neural stimulation.
Oh, it's getting dark.
Wait, what is this?
Okay, nothing.
Okay, oh, it's one of those tests that...
Okay, you gotta do it in the correct order.
Okay, one.
I feel like there is probably something telling you what
this is, but...
He is not truly gone, Victor.
Take the cassette.
hold them in your arms and you will know all life support
systems offline where's the cassette what cassette am I
blind take the cassette actually I have no idea where it is
sir it's so dark in the room oh oh But it's not in there.
The blinky thing.
That one makes it impressive that such a small vessel can
contain something as infinite as a soul.
But a boy should not have to live his life trapped in a
dream.
Snakey though.
This may have been all they could give you.
But I have no such limits.
Keep following the signal, Victor.
This is how you will find him.
This cassette is the key.
You brought it with you on this mission for a reason.
Petro is still with you on your vessel.
Petro!
You just have to remember who stole him from you.
Strata.
You wouldn't download a son.
Mercy, set your son free.
Oh, wait again.
What did he say?
Express Telegram.
From Stepan Adamenko.
To Victor Kaminsky.
You have to go home right now.
All landlines, electronics out of order.
Fires throughout the city.
city.
Can't tell you confidential details.
We have made a mistake.
I fear we cannot undo.
We're on ship with the guy.
No, my tunes.
Oh, man.
Stefan was the guy who was doing the other mission.
And we're on the we're us full of vengeance are on the same
tiny confined space with him
yikes what's it saying this morning about us
yo i had that speaker page 43 civil status father
citizenship under review wait oh my gosh the
responsibilities change too wait criminal history unjust
responsibilities navigator drill vessel piloting find your
son do whatever it takes to bring him back whoa whoa purple
cassette oh okay it's a little tight in here guys a little
tight
solitaire great choice please be safe down there this is the
last time you promised he was one day from retirement
he has his own
dad says grandpa is going to drill deeper than anyone has
drilled before he came by before he would leave and he and
dad looked sad and a bit angry together I asked dad if he
had ever shot a gun, but he said that he hadn't.
He said that there was a big war once, and no one was
allowed to have guns after that.
Is this how the Vostok it is?
Wait, this is our son, Petrol!
This is our chip!
Dad, where are you?
We have the best house.
My friends all think so, too.
Dad says it's because he worked as a navigator.
Primary emotion, pride.
Petro, my son!
I'm right here!
Why is he in here?
I'm cold?
I sat on the floor and played with my toy.
His dad was in the other room.
I like that he can still hear him humming.
Primary emotion, safety, memory, classification, love.
Oh my god.
They downloaded my son.
I'm glad he is with me.
I don't know their faces, but their voices are familiar.
They're smiling at me.
I am safe, I am loved.
Is this when...
Petro is a baby.
You wouldn't download a son.
They downloaded my son!
There's so many things.
There's so many like, Dad, I miss you.
I asked Dad why I don't have a mom.
He got quiet for a bit.
I didn't ask again.
But he said, it said divorced.
So.
They turned my son into an NFT.
Dad, where are you?
We'll read one more.
I stood by the shore and looked at the ocean.
I felt really big.
I kept thinking there could be huge fish or monsters in the
water.
Scary.
Why did you have Petro?
Petro, petro, petro, petro, petro, petro, petro, petro,
petro, petro, wait, if we insert petro into the navigation,
do you think it would give us the coordinates to our sign?
We have a new message.
Yikes.
We still don't have Stepan.
Wait, the lights are off in here.
Why?
Okay, good.
And stay there.
I expected to see what's his name in his room as well.
Alright, still same number of teeth.
All as well.
Ooh, that's not well.
That's not well at all.
Uh.
Hello!
Yes, communications cassette.
Insert.
We have great technology to be able to receive messages like
8,000 meters under the ground.
Technology has come so far, hasn't it now?
M13, I'm sorry to say it, but this mission is a disaster.
It's been several days now since any contact from you.
Time for me to go to bed so I can wake up early for work.
Marco, good night!
Good night!
cutting age for the early 80s i love i love like alt alt
reality like retro you know it's like blade runner you know
where it's it's retro but also like super advanced and
everything so cool it's been several days now since any
contact from you and now you've hit a dead end navigating
through the layers below you is far too precise for our
instruments we can't risk another matroshka incident we are
terminating your autopilot systems in order to save power
while we are discussing extraction well uh that we I will
not allow my son is down there retrofuturism yeah yeah yeah
I assure you no one wants this especially when you are so
close to the m12 vessel well maybe that's what caused it
okay but sometimes you just have to accept reality.
Don't listen to their apathy.
Even if you tried to explain what truly is at stake here,
for you now, would they understand?
Would they care?
You are so close, Victor.
Oh my gosh, the parts are going back and forth.
That's so cool.
If I could bring back Petro right now for you, I would.
But I am bound to this place, and my reach is frustratingly
limited.
But there is no such limitation upon me.
you.
I know you will find a way.
This is so cool!
You just have to get back into that cockpit.
You just have to get back into the cockpit, get back into
cockpit, get back into cockpit, get back into cockpit!
Cool.
Okay.
Oh no, it's dark down there.
I had to take off the fuse remember okay
I'm totally in normal why is everything closed the vessel is
off course oh we've reached 8,000 yippee come on chingy
don't make the earth deity say it again yeah get back in the
what the cockpit Yay!
Let's check out what this guy is about.
Oh wait, sorry, that's the wrong.
Uh, we got the purple, purple cassette.
Dorm 3.
Torpedo room.
Bodan Pluznik.
39.
Married.
Citizenship full.
Criminal history.
Minor.
Responsibilities engineer.
Maintain vessel engine.
Monitor.
Mag.
Sorry, it's so hard to read.
Something generator, repairs in general, and maintenance.
Can't see a mint.
She must be smaller today.
Small body.
Big heart.
What is this emergency, though?
I wonder, wait, what if we call that?
801-641?
What was the last bit?
801-6- I think I took a picture of her.
It's not showing up, but I want to see if it still goes
through, you know.
Eight, eight.
There was an attempt.
All right, just got to get back in the cockpit.
For tomorrow!
Controls locked.
Ground density too high.
Torpedo sequence required.
Access torpedo room, engine hall.
Arm and detonate forward drill torpedo.
Resume drill operation.
Torpedo room?
Uh, it did say that his room was the torpedo room.
Wait, we have his key now, maybe it'll work.
Okay, let's go.
What have we got to lose?
How bad can it be?
I'm so scared.
Me too, Gabe.
Oh, it's already gone.
Calls number.
Hello, I would like to report a cassette napping.
download my son I
want to go home me too oh here here here that's right I
forgot about this one thank
you very much there we go nice little room you got here nice
hat same what the heck is it oh cards
uh-huh there's a lot going on here is this the key to
torpedo fire not ready vital tasks chamber unloaded insert a
torpedo into the firing tube
now where does one acquire said torpedo what
is the second task oh insert a torpedo into the the first oh
well I did said task or something wait how did I do that I
didn't read it what did I do I'm so good at my job oh this
is the padlock oh
team that's not good I've got the padlock
But whenever we see flowers, it's bad news bears.
Is this any different?
No, that's all the same.
All right, one torpedo.
Thank you very much.
Ghosts don't bother me.
I'm having very important work done right now.
Now where do I insert said torpedo?
into the firing tube.
Is it this?
Like here?
Oh, here.
I know how to do this.
I'm an engineer.
Women in STEM.
I was just making sure it was still there.
Obviously.
Duh.
Always double check.
Exactly.
Fire ready.
Chamber loaded, primer engaged.
I press the button.
I release.
And I press again.
Detonate with the clacker.
Okay.
What'd you call me?
Nice.
Should we do another one?
Yeah, it looks like it's still there.
I don't know.
need to like adjust this now do i no okay we gotta go get
another one
how many do i need
keep going keep going i think you missed maybe that'd be so
embarrassing though wouldn't it
now we got where more where that came from exactly uh what
is it Primer.
Place the primer over the tube in coffee.
Huh?
Oh, you?
I'm playing Switch Sports.
Thumb wrestle.
Is this something I gotta do?
No, it just said... It literally won't let me, like, do
anything.
So I just... I go... We just keep... We just keep
detonating, I guess.
Oh,
I got it!
Oh, I see now.
Hit the target with a torpedo.
They give you so many chances.
That's so funny.
Yahoo!
Detonation complete!
Alright.
They're like, you can't mess this up, dummy.
You can't mess this up.
Just, like, pay attention, dummy.
Seriously, just pay attention, dummy.
Wait, dummy?
Are you watching?
Is that
for me?
Don't say internal.
Oh, gosh.
Victor?
Victor, it's Deppan.
Oh, that explosion just now.
That was you, wasn't it?
Maybe.
You don't have to do this.
They'll get us out.
We just have to give them some time.
I know this isn't how either of us wanted this to go, but
others will pick up the torch from us.
Strata disabled the autopilot systems.
I'm the best navigator there is.
This is the depth where the M12 went missing.
Look, I know that thing that got Yosef and Bodan is still in
here with us.
But in my dorm there's...
Don't let them tempt you into surrender.
Since when has anything worthwhile ever been easy?
They will never truly trust you, Victor.
But I do.
Get into the cockpit.
Listen to your insects.
Yeah, the thing?
What about the...
There's been several of those, no?
Wait.
Where are you, Stepan?
I...
That wasn't me, was it?
That might have been my footsteps.
I couldn't tell.
Okay.
Uh, anyway.
I'm going back into the cockpit.
I feel safest in here.
Insert employee ID.
Where?
Where do you want me to do that?
Oh.
Manual piloting needs to be engaged.
Enter four-digit employee ID from your issued dorm cassette.
Oh, why is first two digits?
Okay.
That's me?
Four?
Wait, I can't see the other two.
Oh, wait.
Faint blood on the shell.
A testament for forsaken dreams.
Uh.
Wait, first two digit?
Wait.
Oh, zero four, but...
Oh, oh, I have to go put this in.
I'm silly.
My bad.
We have to see what my ID is.
Like, here.
Okay.
Six, three, five, nine.
Six, three, five, nine, everybody.
We're not at 8,000.
It's a liar.
Where we are.
Six, three, five, nine.
Okay.
All right, we did it.
Okay, cool.
All right.
I can do this.
Insert a neural cassette with a laboratory.
All right.
We got this.
Ooh.
I put in the crystal.
We've learned.
We've learned how to do all of this.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, it's different.
It's different now for real.
Okay.
The X is here.
I look here.
Don't.
14980?
14.980?
14.
What
was it?
980?
Who's gonna be talking me?
Am I off?
Wait, do I have to put in the targeting?
It's this one, right?
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Because the other one's my son.
I don't want to overwrite my son.
Okay.
Can you imagine?
Son, can you hear me?
That'd be so bad.
Alright.
We're navigating.
We're a little drunk.
and we're navigating.
Sun deleted.
All right, X, Y, Z.
Okay, I'm committing to the bit and I'm pushing, I'm
pushing, I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm
ulting.
Success!
Thank you, give me that.
Put you in here.
No nav- oh, wait.
Then do I do the navigation?
Do I have to put the, I don't remember, hold on, I don't
remember this part, yeah, okay, maybe, no, just kidding,
but, did I put it back in here?
Yes, we're recording!
Okay, thank you, then we're doing this, oh, I'm not doing
that, I'm encrypting, what is going on?
Your guess is...
We're doing literally every person's job on this ship.
Wait!
The ground density is min-toll!
Look!
3-3-10!
In 3, Japanese can be...
No, sorry.
Not in 3- In Japanese, 3 can be read as me!
And 10 can be read as toll!
Min-toll!
Oh my gosh.
This mission was made for me, actually.
Wait.
No, that doesn't work.
Dang it.
My 69 got ruined.
Haunting for real?
We'll do like that.
And...
Okay.
Y16?
No.
Uh.
Oh.
Y16X19.
Why are you 16?
X 19.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Follow me, little circle.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, oh, it's moving!
Wait, you guys?
Is this moving?
Uh...
It's moving?
310 is what?
Like 50, 50 ish?
Oh shoot, we lost it?
No, no, no.
Go, go, go.
Am I doing it quickly?
Wait, what does that say?
New target value.
Relocate vessel immediately!
Oh...
Um...
Uh...
Oh,
this way.
60.
Whatever it takes.
Relocate vessel.
Oh my gosh.
Input coordinates.
No.
Oh my gosh.
Are we kidding me right now?
Uh.
Navigation.
No.
Wait, where's my navigation?
Where's my...
Oh, here.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is scary.
This is scary.
This is a little stressful.
Oh shoot.
I did it forgot again.
Ah!
Wait, this is so... This is pretty stressful.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
This is getting pretty intense, huh?
Ground density.
370.
Please, go in there.
Uh, okay.
Oh, this is why we're hitting the magma, huh?
is why we're hitting the magma, huh, guys?
Wait, does this work?
I think it does.
We'll go like 66, 27.
Wait, shoot, what was what?
Why 66?
Okay, but it's also 3.7, right?
Yeah, 3.7.
I'm stressing, I'm stressing!
3.7, 38, 38.
Okay, wait.
66.
All right.
Get me in there.
And it's also...
What was it?
30...
35?
35, right?
38.
Close enough.
Oh my gosh.
This is so stressful.
What the hell?
Why does this have to be so stressful?
Okay.
All right, thank you.
Wait, what, what, what, what?
Level, level, level, level?
Recording successful?
all right encode all right all right all right space let's
go let's go nobody panic we're not panicking please why is
it taking so long we start terminal oh my god please please
oh my gosh have you tried turning it off and on again that's
literally what i just did okay ground density was what 260
260 everybody 260.
all right we're going down down down all right 22
oh my gosh i know y 22 x 82 and then 60 to 62 oh my gosh
wait there's too many numbers I can't keep track.
Crap, I can't, oh, thank you.
Y22, thank you so much.
Oh my gosh.
82, you guys are the best.
Thank you so much.
And then, oh, this was, this was, sorry.
260, 62.
Alright, we're good, we're good.
62, 62.
Too many numbers for me.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh.
Come on, come on!
Save zone!
We have nine minutes.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm the best navigator they've ever seen on this dang earth.
Please.
What does that say?
RPM of 54.
Wait, what does that mean?
Do I have to do this again?
Oh.
Navigation locked.
Oh, my God.
Oh, hold on.
I need a sippy.
Okay.
Oh!
The crystal.
Where's my- Oh, it's in here still.
Uh, I'm on the X, I think.
Wait, am I?
No, I'm too far.
Sorry.
X, okay.
It's up there.
Okay.
Alright, I'm staring.
I'm staring.
We're looking.
What is that?
2189.
Neural cassette.
21.
Of course it would be all the way at the end.
89.
Oh gosh, please.
Tuned!
Thank you!
Open the door!
Open the newer!
Uh, XYZ?
X, Y, Z.
Where's that X, Y, Z?
There, X, Y, Z.
Yes, yes, yes.
All right.
It's fine.
This...
Oh, my...
God.
The signal will...
Wait, what the heck is this?
Is this because...
Oh my god.
Is this because I rewrote my son?
Wait.
Hold on.
801.
Wait, what is this telling me now?
50-50.
33.
My son is helping me, you guys.
Oh my gosh.
Did they do this on purpose, you think?
And what was it?
30?
something
the signal the signal did i get am i getting a bad end i
rewrote my you guys i did the foreshadowing earlier oh my
god we're 40 meters away we're so close safe zone soon it's
not as bad when i taped over oh no oh my god this game not
as bad when i taped over mr plank it's night court times My
nightcore.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay.
I can't, I can't read.
I can't read anything.
What does it say?
Distance to save them.
Input coordinates.
Oh, my God.
Can we read any of this?
Oh, I can get rid of the tapes!
Wait, uh, uh, navigation.
Wait, is it, is it, it's in here.
I won't, let me grab it, there we go.
Okay, wait, it will let me grab it.
Okay, recording successful?
I can imagine me, I am like leaning up to everything, being
like, huh, huh?
This is so relatable.
It actually is!
Did I...
Did I go over my son?
Why did that take so long?
Ground density was 2-2, everybody.
2-2-20.
Okay.
Luckily, I can at least see this, I think.
Gosh, this is stressful.
this is a this game is kind of insane okay 71 53 uh i'll
check this after 71 wait 53 71 no 71 wait 53 71 I keep
mixing them up okay and then it was 220 which is 70 70 70 70
Oh my gosh.
Where am I at?
Wait, I can't read it.
One, two, three, four, five.
Oh my gosh.
This is trippy.
This is horribly trippy.
What are you saying now?
Controls locked?
Ground density too high.
Oh my god.
Are we for real?
Sorry, I keep pausing because I'm like, this is a lot.
This is a lot.
I'm running through here blind, for real.
The game is rage-baiting, actually.
How am I supposed to do this, blind?
Because I'm the best to ever do it, baby.
I'm the best navigator ever.
That's why.
I'm the best to ever do it.
never do it.
I'm the best navigator ever.
Yeah, baby.
Okay.
Vital task zero.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No.
Is this part of the game?
Wait.
Uh.
Mole game has crashed and will Low level fatal error.
Ran out of memory.
The paging file is too small for this operation to complete.
Wait, is this part of the game?
No, I don't think so.
Petro.
Petro's revenge.
Oh my god.
Wait, let's open it back up, team, and let's see what...
Oh, this can't be real.
Please, please, please.
It would be a boss suspense move to have the game just crash
at the end.
No, I can't believe this.
I can't believe this.
No, no, no.
It does say continue.
But where did it last save?
You know?
We have to see it.
Oh.
Where it last saved.
If it's the torpedo, that's fine.
Looks like we might actually be the worst dead.
Happy Father's Day, everybody.
Oh!
No, all of that again.
Oh my god.
I'd have to do that whole sequence again.
You could try not to overwrite Petro.
Yeah, true.
Okay.
Holy cow.
Really?
This is a rough spot.
I'm not gonna lie, you guys.
This is...
This is not where I would like to be at.
63.59.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Save Petro.
Save the world.
I need to see where I'm standing.
There we go.
1498.
Okay.
So this...
These are the same numbers.
Here, and then we get our neural cassette.
This one says Petro.
It is the targeting cassette, everybody.
It is the targeting cassette.
Don't let me pick the neural cassette.
Oh, did we have a raid?
Thank you!
So much, thank you!
The rest in Glitch Face, thank you for the gift.
Targeting cassette, targeting cassette, targeting cassette.
Oh my gosh We were so close I think that's the worst part We
were so close Okay XYZ Thank you so thank you Dorgo thank
you No, well thank you Hello Push
We try again Oh, my bad Uh-huh Alright, now our navigation.
Phew.
Oh, ready to record!
Successful!
I love that my son helped me though, that was so cute.
Preload the targeting cassette in the lab before digging.
That is so smart.
That's really smart.
That's pretty smart.
I can't guarantee that it won't, um, you know.
Oh,
there we go.
That it can't, that it won't, the game won't crash again.
And the torpedo.
How much, did I?
Uh, I only had to do this while I was blind, right?
I think I only had to do this while I was, oh, it won't let
me.
Oh, detonation complete.
Yeah, I won't let me.
That sucks.
We tried, though.
Um, yeah.
That was a good attempt, though.
Uh, alright.
You.
Wait.
310.
Yeah, I'm Minto again.
Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto.
Okay, avoid the magma.
Why is this?
This looks different though, right?
Hmm.
All right.
Y16.
No.
Dang it.
No, wait.
Oh, yeah.
Y18X17.
And it's 310, which is about 50.
Y18.
If you guys don't mind helping me with numbers, that would
be awesome.
18.
17.
Okay.
It's about, what, 30, we said?
That was so intense, though.
That was really intense, so...
I'll try it.
Thank you for the donut!
I can't read it right now, but thank you.
The RPM.
Oh, it's 50.
Oh, thank you.
I was like, what are you saying?
There we go.
I was like, why isn't it going dark?
Am I crazy?
Okay, here we go.
Uh, please, please, please.
Oh, did that work?
Okay.
60.
11.
Is it gonna fail?
Okay.
Processing.
Dump.
370.
Hmm.
58.
26.
58, 26.
Okay, and then it was 3.7, so it's 38.
Nits, okay.
Once again...
It's a little tedious, which is, like, the least thing that
you want to do.
In, uh...
In a horror game.
It's tedium.
But, it is what it is.
Because usually these segments, like the segment, if it ends
up being a little too long, it's just kind of like, ugh,
okay, okay.
Oh, is this the one that's going to make me restart the
computer?
Yeah, okay.
The crashing make you repeat is really rough.
Yeah, yeah.
I know, I did already go through it.
I did my job.
260.
Can you guys remember 62 for me, please?
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Aibu.
All right.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, 21.
62, 62.
21.
84.
21, 84.
Oh, I should keep pressing the wrong buttons.
And 62, right?
Yeah, I remember.
Thank you.
Show me.
What is this?
2189.
I think that's what it was before.
Yep, it exactly was.
Let him guide you.
Oh wait, there's a whole cutscene.
Wait a second.
There's a whole cutscene for this that we entirely missed.
Because I used to buy a son on accident!
It forces you!
Averse!
Why it crashed?
No freaking way.
That's so funny.
So I'm not a bad father after all, everybody.
We overwrote our son on purpose!
Uh, here.
Petro, my son, got- Now, now I feel a bit better.
I'm like, my son will guide me.
My son guide me.
Yes, my son will guide me.
Hold on, I want to take it with me.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, yes.
Here he is.
He's guiding me.
Uh, wait.
Uh, okay.
Uh, 50-50-33.
My son is the best to ever do it.
50-50.
Come on, son.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's go, son.
We're 60 meters to save zone.
We got this, son.
You and me?
You're guiding me?
Because you're awesome.
51.
I have a feeling we're not going to be able to avoid the,
uh, you know, torpedo nonsense, but...
Well, at least I'm 14.
There it is.
Can you call the number?
I'm not sure.
to be honest but um get rid of this get rid of this and this
and this and put the uh put you navigation in there the
lever okay
we yeah we broke our glasses so successful okay encrypt or
decrypt or whatever the heck it's doing reading read it
Why didn't he keep the one lens he had?
There's no time!
You don't understand!
Alright, get rid of all this junk.
My son was trying to help, but he actually caused great
problems for us.
Alright.
This guy...
Yeah, no time to see!
No time!
I just have to go off pure instinct because I'm a gamer.
I'm going off my gamer instincts.
71.51.
Easy.
Easy to remember.
Wait.
And it was 220.
Can you guys remember 70?
Oh, wait.
That's all the way up, isn't it?
Okay.
Wait.
71.51.
71.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
All right.
And we're cranking that.
Bed in shul.
You are there.
You can read that.
Let's go!
Pause stream to read.
Wait, where am I?
There we go.
Okay, let's go get a torpedo.
Who restocked these?
Petro take the wheel!
Petro don't crash don't crash the game Petro my boy my boy
please please let me finish the game my boy my boy all right
that's it right yep okay all right moment of truth everybody
Finkies crossed Finkies crossed Finkies Christ I got an
achievement clear that out manual thing did we do it Oh, oh
shoot.
Uh, excuse me.
What's that say?
Safe distance reach, cleared of hazard, turn off vessel.
Turn it off.
You made it through.
Now you are close.
Very close.
Look at me.
It's time I made you see.
now you have to hurry you must save him oh it's saved oh
thank goodness uh do I have a fire extinguisher can I take
that alright excuse me excuse me excuse me usage as well
where's my son is he in the computer my son is the computer
everybody please please move uh actually i'm where where am
i going oh here this way okay fire follow the fire oh it's
saving again why wait no we're saving him from the actual
fire my son oh god oh god okay I think this way.
My actuals...
Is it 3-11 that I have to go to?
Wait, in here maybe?
Wait.
My son!
Oh my gosh.
Whoa, whoa.
My vision's going black, black.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Wait.
I think I need to go back.
Oh, there's like a real time limit here.
Okay.
Good.
Maybe if I clear fire...
Oh my gosh.
My son!
Over here?
Okay, okay.
Keep going, keep going.
The comic is stressful.
I know, right?
For me too.
We can change the past.
We can save him.
Is it him?
My son!
Am I parkoring?
What is going on?
I need gamer paint.
I can't see anything at the moment.
Whoa.
This is intense.
Okay.
We're gonna have to run through.
Oh, I can't see anything.
Here.
Okay.
Alright.
In here.
Get back out.
Okay.
We could save him, we could save him, guys.
Uh, here?
Wait.
I have to, like, figure out where I need to go, you know?
Uh,
I'm just getting every fire.
Anytime I see a fire, we get it, we get it.
Okay.
Ugh!
Okay, cool.
Alright, alright.
Petrol!
Alright, oh here.
Okay.
We're fine, we're fine.
My son!
Where are you, son?
Where are you, my son?
Wait, is this a...
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Wait, I can't crawl.
Oh, I can crawl.
Oh my gosh.
We're using every game of panic now.
Keep going, keep going, keep going!
Am I not crawling?
Oh, I'm very slow.
I'm very slow.
I'm very slow, everybody.
Please understand.
Oh my gosh.
Please keep going.
Keep going.
Oh, here this way.
Oh, my goodness.
I lost my thing, I think.
My son.
I'll make it for you!
Oh, oh.
That was close.
Gosh, this earthquake did the numbers.
My son!
Kaminsky!
It didn't matter that you hurried home as fast as you could.
They called it the Matroska incident.
Strata had refused to let the drilling missions be the thing
of the past.
Instead, they ventured beyond where your kind were ever
meant to go.
And awoke things that should have been left sleeping.
But Strata never paid for their mistakes.
You did.
Oh, yeah.
That's why it was 3-11.
That was our home.
Which also is like kind of a...
Oh my god, I hear him screaming.
Fun!
We never made it back to him in time.
That's like the date of like that huge, you know, reactor
earthquake.
and tsunami and you owe them nothing, Victor.
In Japan, 311.
My
desk is clean.
Everything's cleaned off.
Digit 2.3?
That's confusing.
Offer of enlistment.
Victor, your rejection of our offer saddens me.
will be one of a kind.
A true revival of the good old days, if you'll forgive my
sentimentality.
Still, I want you to know that I understand your decision.
I know your father and you never saw eye to eye.
And now you are a father yourself.
It's a heavy burden to bear, but I'm certain you will handle
it with the same care, tenderness, and unfailing effort that
you seem to give to everything in your life.
I'm proud of you, signed Stefan Ad-a-d-a-d-a-damenco.
Yeah.
Prospect Amira 18.
Let's see what it says.
Adamska, I know.
I think of it too.
Father Savior is a citizenship.
Criminal history, not enough.
Responsibilities!
Dig, dig, dig, dig, dig, dig, dig, dig, dig!
Dig!
Oh, whoops.
The second...
That's not my mistake.
It's now...
It now...
It says neural...
Oh, wait.
It did say neural before.
I'm silly.
I was thinking...
For some reason, I thought it said petrol before.
We have a new message.
Yeah, what is it?
Okay.
What do you want, huh?
Dig, dig!
I wanna dig, I wanna dig, dig!
I wanna keep digging, I wanna keep digging, baby!
You're denying me of my purpose.
Whoever is read M13, whoever is reading this.
I'm so sorry.
We finally had an update from Stefan about the state of the
mission.
About Yosef.
about whatever monstrosity has made its way onto the vessel
with you.
If only we'd known.
The following information is absolutely critical.
In Stefan's dorm, there is a gun case.
There's just a single bullet on board for the most
unthinkable of emergencies.
Yeah, where has he been?
I hope it can say...
Maybe he's been locked in his room the whole time?
I hope it can save you now.
Make that shot count for tomorrow.
Sure.
Ooh, creepy.
Wait, I'm...
Heading this way.
Auto correction enabled.
Uh, I'm...
So do I go to his room?
Which one was...
Oh, room is down here.
Okay.
Whoa, he's got a mech on the, on his, in his room.
That's awesome.
What's this?
I can't read it.
Oh, this is a phone.
But the middle digit is three.
The cornerstone.
8,754 meters, a new low.
This case is only to be opened if met with an insurmountable
emergency.
All crew members need to be un-unanimously.
Agreed to open this case.
Therefore, each crew member has been assigned one digit at
random.
May God help you, Strata.
Digit three, five.
So what is it?
The second one was, wait, second one was three?
Uninomously.
Three, five.
I hate to say I told you so, Stefan.
You were the one who put this crew together.
You knew some of your selections were, shall you, say,
controversial.
And above all, you knew what risks those selections would
bring.
Look, I'm not trying to be heartless.
All I'm saying is that this is not one of the situations I
can bail you out from.
You need to make some tough decisions.
Too much is riding on this mission.
We should reserve extraction for a true...
They weren't even going to extract us.
Also, pirate, I just saw your don't know.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, luckily things seem okay right now.
Unanimously.
Oh,
you're gonna extract him?
What else is new?
I know, of course not, right?
The symptoms of the crew are experiencing could very well be
because you are several kilometers below the surface.
It doesn't have to be the signal.
I hate this person.
Let me just start by saying we are all devastated about
Hritsenko's death.
God took away my ability to see sorry he was one of those
geniuses that felt larger than life but that doesn't change
anything step on step in you're going to have to keep going
no matter what I understand the situation is dire but that
enough is not grounds for extraction and Herzenko is not
truly needed to operate the vessel is he the signal target
coordinates seem to have been updated without issue it's
natural you feel responsible for the crew.
You are.
But they also knew the risks.
This is not like the M12 mission.
You know what you are up against.
And then there's one more.
This is the most recent one.
I'm not about to let your stubbornness be the death of you.
You, if anyone, should know that sometimes a commander has
to face reality.
Step on.
I'm telling you, this is a friend.
without central command permission heads will roll you know
how the situation is up here the earthquakes the constant
blackouts the dead who won't shut up as long as even a
single crew member remains alive the public won't accept you
giving up we can't always save everyone we care about step
on when we extract we are going to need someone to take
responsibility and no step on it won't be
you all righty well quite bleak huh yikes yeah oh I'm not
grabbing anything I'm shutting the door which I don't want
to do I'm trying to go down the stairs?
Am I in the right spot?
Yeah, because there's the water closet.
I don't want to go in there.
That's terrifying.
Never mind.
The wreck room should be down here, no?
What?
Oh, maybe I have to go into the other rooms.
That's right.
To find the number, the digits, right?
Is there a light?
Here we go.
Since everyone's been given one?
Hmm.
Yeah, everybody's room number.
Oh, here we go.
Digit 4 is 7!
Alright.
Digit 4.
7.
Alright, and that just leaves one more.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, so tight in there.
Oh, creepy.
Oh, creepy, creepy, creepy.
Oh, digit one is eight.
All right.
Haki-daki.
How interactive.
I feel like using this on Stepan.
Wait, it's missing it.
Where's the bullet?
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, that don't sound good.
Where's the bullet?
Uh, the computer turned off?
Oh.
Internal?
The extraction process has begun.
No, it hasn't.
The mission is canceled.
They're bringing us home.
Strata will claim the mission failed because of sabotage.
This is such a... this is so lie.
Of course, we both know the truth is a bit more complicated
than that.
I did everything I could to protect you.
All I can do now is tell you how sorry I am.
I should have never brought you to this God-forsaken place.
If there is blame in this mission, it begins and ends with
me.
But they won't write my name in the report.
It will be yours.
History doesn't punish the guilty, it punishes the
convenient.
I know you did all that you could.
And I want you to know I will always be proud of you, shot
uh yeah this is so where's my bullet where's the bullet at
step on step oh it's really hard to see oh the game just
saved again how much longer is it i wonder
uh i can't see anything oh
Oh, I'm just walking towards something.
What is this?
The white rabbit!
Oh my god!
It's the white rabbit!
Follow the white rabbit.
I'm running?
I'm following the white rabbit signal.
Bunny!
So cute!
Hey there, bunny.
Hey there, Bonnie.
Cute little bunny.
Oh,
this is so peaceful.
Wow.
Is this the signal?
Deeper and deeper into the wood.
Hey there, Bonnie.
You don't need to run from me.
I'm just going to pet your head and scratch you a little in
the good spots.
Like your bum.
Every animal likes a good scratch in the bum, right guys?
Wow.
Oh, this is just like when we were playing the...
Or not playing, but at the beginning when we were in that
field, you know.
Oh, wow, so cute.
It's leading me to false sense of security now, isn't it?
Oh, hello.
Time to dig, dig, dig.
My favorite thing.
The whole...
We're all mad here.
Go down the rabbit hole.
Hello, bunny.
It's really dark.
Am I in the center of the earth?
Did I do it?
Did I dig all the way to...
You know... Did you guys ever think that if you dug through
the earth, you'd get to China?
Where am I?
Oh.
Ooh.
And then in the playground at school, you start digging.
Oh, man.
Now we get a flashlight.
Oh, okay.
Horrifying.
Bunny?
Maybe they want me to dig here.
Bunny, I'm scared.
Bunny?
I don't have any of my items or anything.
We're in full madness mode, I guess.
Is this where Stepan's been the whole time?
In his...
Oh!
That was a bunny.
Bunny over here?
Following the bunny?
What the...
Oh, okay.
Love this.
Alright.
This is really awesome.
What's that saying?
Crazy zoom in.
It looks...
I thought it was a big old...
nose.
Why is my heart racing so much?
Nightmare fuel.
Oh my gosh, guys, we're in the nutty putty cave.
He was crawling through the cave when he fell down and was
greeted by bunnies.
The bunnies laughed at him and caused a boulder to fall from
the ceiling, reducing him to a shape.
Why is this music scary?
Oh, oh my god!
Wait, who is this?
Hello?
Oh, we're not gonna...
That's it.
That's... Hello?
What the hell?
What's that for?
The guy who died in the nutty putty cave!
No!
Whoa, wee!
We're just gonna keep going.
We're not even gonna address the skelly in the room.
All right.
Ooh, it's a tight fit, tight squeeze.
Oh, oh no, why?
Why did that happen?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
This is becoming very iron lung.
All who tried to get to the signal.
Oh man!
Oh my god, the glasses!
Wait, everybody's a nerd!
Is this me?
Am I a nerd?
Sorry you had to see me like that.
I'm not the only one.
Oh, shoot.
No, no.
It didn't mean it.
That is me.
You have to make a choice, Victor.
Follow my light.
Or let them devour you.
Who?
Who's them?
Oh, gosh.
They're hitting every...
Oh, my God.
Ah!
I didn't see the light.
Wait.
He devoured me immediately.
They're hitting like every fear, every phobia, no?
Oh, well, I guess we let them devour us.
This is so craziness.
What does this say?
They feared the world unaligned with the tyranny of their
dogma.
Thus the angel was condemned and cast down.
I don't know what I grabbed.
No, I don't think so.
The angel taught truth and secrets.
Only she truly understood.
Yeah, yeah.
That's our thing.
No?
That's the mag...
That's the...
What's it called?
We've been following?
Right?
A crystal, yeah, yeah.
A rock.
Come in.
Was there anything else?
I like the music.
Oh.
All flesh withers.
Some flowers are out before they can bloom.
The people mourn the ways of the world.
Okay, okay.
People mourn the ways of the world.
They're mourning.
They're sad.
I don't know if it's this one or...
An angel descended onto the earth, the first witness lay
wrapped in swaddled cloth.
This one?
She's laying in swaddled cloth?
Or...
Yeah.
What is this one?
The angel was imprisoned beneath the earth.
The knowledge he had given them became his chains.
So...
No, this one, the baby.
The baby.
I got it.
This one must be...
Oh, this one.
Right?
I wish I could put these down.
Because I can't read it now.
Oh!
I'm too good.
Just kidding.
They broke me, Victor.
Oh.
I can't even remember her name.
But I refuse to let you suffer my fate.
She.
Oh my god.
This is not the end.
Like Petro, I still live on, trapped in static.
His cassette is the key.
It is what will bridge the gap between us.
Between life and death.
It is how you will set us both.
free whoa oh my god like water breaks stone over the ages
the past that binds us both can be washed away so take the
Iwo what is that wash away all those memories of funerals
and loss and death forever oh my god cool yoink Go, go, go,
go, go.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Oh, what am I doing?
Uh-oh.
Oh, that's gasoline.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Ah!
One last smoke, everybody.
Second smoke, baby.
One more for the road.
Flick it.
it.
A little bit more.
Oh, just one more.
You gotta savor it.
Yeah, down to the filter, baby.
Oh.
There's like nothing left of this.
Oh!
My.
What do we...
What do you...
to do?
What do I do after all this?
I have no inventory.
I can run.
Let them suffer.
Oh, turn around.
Yeah, external call.
Hello?
Navigator.
Do you copy?
This is vessel M12.
Well, what remains of We thought they left us here to rot.
Loyalty doesn't tend to be rewarded in this business.
That said, we're sure glad to have you here.
You're part of Adamenko's crew, aren't you?
Uh-huh.
And that explosion just now was your doing, yeah?
A crazy way to make a path between our vessels for sure, but
we'll take it.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
We did find what we were looking for all this time, you
know.
The signal source is here, just a few meters beneath us.
I've got to say, I've never seen anything so beautiful.
Make your way over to us, yeah?
What?
We'll dig our way out of this hole together.
But be careful, son.
are old, sinister things down here that might be best left
forgotten.
And I get the feeling they don't want us to leave.
Oh, the game just saved again.
Okay.
Very cool.
Oh, no.
I have my inventory back.
My revolver.
Oh, geez.
Guys, I'm...
I wish I had bullets.
Wee!
What is that?
Okay.
Nice note, kid.
Sunshine and things.
Alright.
How...
This game is so long.
That's okay, though.
I'm having fun.
I hope you guys are too.
I know it's late.
I'm sorry.
Uh, this looks like a boss room.
What the hell?
Uh, okay.
Um.
Fuse is again?
Is it the same?
Let's check.
Wait, what's this?
Hidden treasure to save Dad.
Okay.
And is it the same?
same.
Uh, rotate to match the amount of fuses.
Press and hold the red glowing light.
Step four.
Yeah, the bunny.
One, three, the same.
Okay, it's all the same.
Do you think it's actually?
What if it's the thing again?
Oh gosh.
Flashlight all of a sudden.
It's the thing to kill me.
Wait, that's what I just did, no?
Isn't this the one I just opened?
The thing to save that?
Oh, I walked off the thing.
Oh, we need a yellow fuse.
Oh, okay.
You're right.
You guys are right.
We need to go into...
Oh, it shows the fuse there.
What's gonna be here though?
What's gonna be in there?
You know?
I'm nervous about that.
What's gonna be in there?
Hello.
Oh, it's open.
Oh, man.
I'm nervous.
Oh my god, what are these?
Oh, angels.
Okay.
Step on.
Is that you?
Is that yours?
I'm neighbors.
I'm neighbors for sure.
Oh god.
I just want to quit this game.
Sorry, hold on.
Oh, I've been using like a very uncomfortable chair I think
I won't probably be able to stream oh we're in the hospital
again yeah so long until I get my chair back you know what I
mean it's not uncomfortable it's just tough to sit in for a
long time I might have to gonna find my way back?
There's no way!
There's no way.
Oh, step on?
Just keep going, I guess.
What is that?
Oh, ew.
Where the heck are we?
For real?
Okay.
Oh,
is my son, does he have the fuse that we need?
Oh, my fragile son.
Do you have the fuse?
Oh, you do.
Oh, my son has the fuse.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, son.
Oh, I
knew we would have to at some point.
So this way...
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Please leave me alone.
Sorry, son.
Happy Father's Day!
Anyway.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh god.
I have to do it so fast.
Wait.
I hate this.
No.
Okay.
Oh god.
You have to do it while running.
I have this.
Put it in.
One.
Please.
No!
What did I do wrong?
Guys, what did I do wrong?
Petrol!
Petro chill!
Petro chill.
What did I do wrong?
We missed three.
Oh, I did?
Okay.
I'm looping him.
I'm looping
him.
I'm looping him.
Oh shoot, oh shit, he's right behind me.
He's gonna get me.
He's gonna get my ass.
What?
Oh my god, he's gonna get my ass for real.
Holy cow, I saw a shadow.
Oh my god, I saw a shadow right behind me.
Oh my god, oh my computer's dying, you guys.
Oof, this part is not kind on me.
Oh, this part, oh, everything's lagging.
Okay.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Press a button!
Sorry.
I was pushing it.
Oh god.
Any door.
Any number.
Oh.
Wrong number?
Sorry, son.
Anyway.
It pains me to do this.
Happy Father's Day.
Bye-bye.
I just picked the number.
I hope it worked.
Oh, good.
The game saved.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, wow.
What's going on in here?
I want to go deeper down than anyone.
It's written better.
Oh.
Oh, it's a cutscene.
Oh, that's horrifying.
Holy cow.
Okay.
please oh my god
oh my god oh he's so skinny holy point blank kill the
monster
He has to wear the most belt ever.
Board the other vessel, find recording equipment, record my
essence onto Petro's cassette.
Bring the cassette to me, bring us together so that I can
bring him back to you.
Snatched waste.
It's a blank!
I am...
Love and hate.
That was really freaky though, that was so, oh, am I okay?
Did I break my neck falling down?
Don't tell me that, that'd be so sad.
It's a blank.
He does laugh gaily, doesn't he?
Wait, do I have a, I have nothing, okay.
And I can't follow the light.
I'm following the darkness.
I can't see anything.
Maybe I do follow the light.
Oh, here we go.
Oh.
On?
Makes sense to me.
This is as far as those who came before you made it.
But for you, that is not the end.
Oh, this is not the end.
Attempting restart.
So we came from up here, but it's Oh my gosh, they also
leave the toilet up.
Wait, what's that?
Typical horror game having to reach into the toilet?
Or not, maybe?
Okay, just kidding.
Am I blind?
Oh, what's this over here?
First-noon, welcome back!
Jeff, thank you!
It's rolled over to my birthday!
Happy birthday, Joff!
Happy birthday!
Thank you!
I'm so sorry that you can't see me, but I'm wishing you a
happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Report.
April 3rd, 79.
We finally managed to pick up readings of the signal.
It's weak, but it's definitely something there with its own
signature.
Good to know we didn't drill all this way for nothing.
I see the cassette in the toilet.
Let me add it.
Fatal error.
User corrupt.
I like the music.
Am I not supposed to grab this out of the toilet?
I guess not.
Um.
Where would they like me to go?
Is the question now.
Oh, yeah, see, there's a player there.
That I would like...
There's stairs?
There are?
Are they over here?
Oh, I see them.
Thank you.
My goodness.
The VTuber is blind.
Cut extraction cables?
Four against.
She wants us to dig.
Dig.
that's freaky oh my gosh they all got look you opened your
eyes to truly see salvation is not something to be found
through prayer or by chance you have to take it for yourself
oh their own crystal look at that oh more crystal oh whoa
Oh, excuse me.
Soon the wait is over.
Oh, yes.
We need to give you my son.
Petro.
Record me onto the cassette together with Petro.
Let this world without him finally be undone.
I think there's somebody over here, too.
Yeah, I think that's another body.
Right here.
Freaky.
The crystals are so pretty.
Oh, and another body.
I didn't even notice this guy.
Alrighty.
Petro, my son.
Maybe become a lovely angel lady.
Signal too weak.
Recording not possible.
What does that mean?
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Press switch.
Oh, I did it.
Is it a skull?
That'd be kind of funny.
Nope, it's...
We're so damn close.
But I still can't reach him.
Get into the pilot seat, Victor.
One last time.
Break through all that which still keeps him from you.
Look at the eyes.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's so creepy.
Excuse me.
Wait, do I need to look at them?
Whoa.
Insert keys.
Oh, here we go.
Excuse me.
There you go.
I can't get in the seat.
Am I gonna be sitting in this guy?
It says Kaminsky on it.
Wait, this is, it says my name on the guy's.
I can't, I don't know how far we did
it.
Breakthrough death.
Oh, 70, it does say 70 RPM.
Central!
Nothing lies between us now.
Oh, the crystals make the recording.
To save your son, press the switch.
Save us both before this all falls apart.
I'm overwriting our memories.
No!
My son!
Oh, he was just a pale and some cat and a car.
too had waited thank you victor for all that you've given me
in return i merely hope to give you the peace you have so
truly earned as for me i fear i'll never be able to let go
he was just a tree but don't worry i won't keep you petro
has already waited long enough
my son
Whoa.
We're not.
Is it really?
Is it real?
There's like these ghost objects in the game.
I truly can't tell if it's because I have the quality on
low.
Like, that thing is kind of see-through, you know?
It's all a little funny.
It's probably because I have the quality on low.
Oh my gosh.
Were we making a box to give this to his...
To give him as a present?
Dear Petro, the day I'm writing this, you are just turning
six.
My plan is to give you this letter by the day you turn 16.
Or perhaps when you get your first job.
Or perhaps when you are married.
When does a child stop being a child?
I can tell you that when I look at you now, making noises
with your toy drill.
Or when you draw with all the colors that you have.
because perhaps soon the rain will be gone and we can go to
the playground right now i feel that you will always be my
little boy forever i wonder what kind of young man you will
be by the time i give this letter to you will you be a
rascal or a studious bookworm will you go to the strata
institute to be a navigator like your dad i hope not you'll
probably be a bit ashamed of me as teenagers usually are the
only other thing i can say for certain is that no matter
what path you choose in life i will always love you your
father victor
why this is a crazy game yeah see it's the quality is like
not great but that's because i have it on low man this is
quite the game to play on father's day isn't it
Drilling in Exploration Division Offer of Enlistment
Victoria, rejection often saddens me Offer saddens me, but I
want you to know that I understand I know your father and
you never saw I die And now you are a father yourself Yeah
We read that one The tapes, the tapes
My boy Honorable D This is to certify that it appears by the
registers of the Institute of Strata that Victor Kaminsky in
the examination for the degree of engineering and boring in
accordance with the statutes of the state kept the
prescribed residence and passed all the necessary
examinations on the 28th of June 1962.
We got all our teeth, no psycho in the shower.
Everything is a happy day.
Oh, my uniform.
Okay, we can't leave.
Dude got a boring award.
I know, right?
What a snores fest this guy is.
Oh, it's so cute.
He doesn't want to go down.
He wants to go to space.
Look at that glorp right there.
That's an absolute glorp.
If I've ever seen one.
A remarkable reward.
revival just when he thought old man Kaminsky had lost his
touch when he does it again.
Teres Kaminsky, who became a household name when he cemented
the record for deepest descent in 1964, describes himself as
someone who has always been a restless soul.
Back in the heydays of drilling, they just couldn't keep me
away from the ground.
Put the picture upside down.
Kaminsky says, the people of Strata used to say, I must be
part mole it's been nine years since strata's last man deep
earth drilling mission destabilized bedrock and falling
mineral prices have been some of the response reasons why
vessels such as the m12 or figure it'll be put on the shelf
is this like a universe where everything went right it felt
right somehow kaminsky laughs when asked about why he chose
to accept a mission that is as daring as it is dangerous the
m12 and i have been through a lot to When Strata unveiled
the mission and I just thought to the mission I just thought
to myself no way I'm letting anyone else go down with her
Pancakes oh yeah My son draws anime
Feels more like just the past Maybe
She's getting hungry now Maybe I've been at dinner yet Is
that my son swinging?
Swing swinging?
Is this actually...
In Russia, they're called blin.
Cute!
My son!
My son is swinging!
Happy end!
At last, find petrol.
My boy!
What's this, what are the noises for?
This is everything?
This lady sucks, almost.
But don't worry, you will be the first to watch it.
I should warn you though.
It's not a pretty sight.
Yes, Mr. President.
Just hand me the tape.
This is the lady that's been like emailing us.
over with your first recording right starts right at
entering the m13 extraction uh oh tape one
yes no sir yeah maria oh saints stephan i should have done
more to protect you oh my god it's the credit scene you
stubborn idiot.
This is so cool.
Do you need a moment?
Keep rolling the tape.
Oh, he's the monster that we stabbed.
We tried to lure him into Stefan's office with the gun as
bait.
He shouldn't have been able to get out, let alone get a hold
of any of the bullets.
Couldn't Adamenco have used the gun himself?
He was adamant that Victor wasn't himself, that it would
have been wrong You are right.
Stefan should have shot him.
Oh shoot.
Oh cool!
He stabbed him multiple times with a screwdriver.
Stefan was desperate to find something in Yosef's research
that could help him even after the killing.
Some things just can't be solved.
There were other signs of body trauma as well.
Most seem to be consistent with signal sickness.
Guess they were all affected.
Yes, Kaminsky was just the most susceptible.
Remarkable in some sense that Kaminsky still managed to get
them to the M12 vessel.
So that did actually happen.
Oh my god!
Such cool credits.
The M13 was so beat up at that point that they couldn't even
perform any conventional docking maneuvers.
So Kaminsky used the old war torpedoes to blast his way
through the hole.
As the engineer.
Oh, Baudins tried to stop him.
Negative.
He believed he was the first one Kaminsky killed.
Seems to have been something with Pluznik that really set
Kaminsky off.
It's like he tried to rip his body apart.
Now for the M12 vessel.
This is where things get truly weird.
These rival narrator stories are so cool.
This is such a cool ending!
The old crew was long gone.
No surprises there, but Kaminsky did manage to use their
recording equipment.
Poor bastards.
Bet you.
Kaminsky used what appears to be one of those Vostok
cassettes that he had brought with him on the mission.
He was clearly delirious beyond all human reason at that
point.
Though he still seems intent on actually completing the
mission.
Did he?
Did he get a recording of the signal?
I don't.
We haven't verified that.
I...
Oh, I didn't realize I could move until last second.
With all due respect, I wonder if it's wise to play such a
recording if one exists.
This mission was never about wisdom.
This has been about damage control from the start.
And now we are here and so much damage has already been
done.
I just need to know it wasn't all for nothing.
Which Kaminsky, us?
For tomorrow then?
Oh, Petro!
For tomorrow.
Unless?
Not tomorrow.
Today!
Bring the vengeance, exactly.
Angel, do your thing.
I say, poison.
Whoa.
What was that?
Everybody in here.
Maria, be gone.
Oh.
I
like how Maria is not even like, face.
Ooh.
Whoa.
Oh my god, all the lights outside even.
Oh.
Oh, the flowers, they're brewing.
The eyeball is showing.
Oh, I think it's a little white, lady.
Oh, this is what happened to my computer earlier.
Whoa!
Reenactment?
Hold on.
Let's see if there's any more that it wants to show us.
Oh, this is way too cool.
Alrighty.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It does crash at the end.
I know, right?
It's fake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Whoa!
We brought about, like, the end of the world.
All right, Petro.
Days until salvation.
Okay.
Let me just give it all.
Restart.
Salvation is here!
That was wild.
That was really wild.
Whoa.
Salvation.
Yeah, this is what computers look like when you're updating.
Doing an update.
Well guys, that was Mo!
That was really fun.
That was really freaky.
Now I'm gonna go turn on every light in my maid cafe because
I'm a little freaked out.
This game was so cool!
I hope you guys liked it too.
Um...
But...
Yeah, thank you so much for hanging out with me today!
Let me play this little quirky new horror game.
It was very cool.
Very, very...
Yeah, Iron Lung Meats.
What's it called?
Iron Lung Meats.
Mouthwashing.
In a great way.
Darko, thank you!
Incredibly proud of you for pushing through the scuff at the
start.
Keeping on after the game crashed and handling the crazy
stress.
Thank you!
Happy Father's Day!
I really liked this.
I really, really like this.
Grunkle, thank you so much for the toy to get to, thank you.
Yeah, spooky.
I want to know something spooky.
Almost fully dodged cannibalism, but it happened because of
a painting.
Oh my god, you're right.
Wait, at number hours, 11 minutes.
311.
Oh, oh, at 3 hours, 11 minutes.
Wait, that's actually creepy.
That's actually creepy.
Kojumbo does it again.
Have you played Iron Lung?
I've played Iron Lung.
I actually haven't watched the movie yet.
But I have played it.
It's been a minute since I last played it.
But yeah.
Yay!
Well guys, I'm gonna head out then.
Thank you so much for hanging out with me.
And I had a lot of fun.
I hope you did too.
And I'll see you when I see you next.
Latamito!
Sorry for all the scuff at the beginning.
Sorry that I haven't been...
on the screen at all.
Fake date, thank you for the pic!
But, yeah, I appreciate you being patient with me while we
got through it, so.
Really, really cool game.
Gatsumito!
Gatsumito, everybody!
Thank you, thank you!
Goodbye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
I will let you guys know, I don't know when I will stream
again.
I will try for the collab.
um well i will see if my computer can handle can handle it
bye bye bye